HEARING OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEES WILL COME TO ORDER.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RARE IT RAY IS AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
OUR PANELISTS FOR JOINING US
TODAY. THIS HEARING FOCUSES.
THE FEDERAL COMMUNITY SERVICES
BLOCK GRANT AND HOW IT IS
ADMINISTERED IN CALIPERS. AS
SUCH IT SERVES TWO PURPOSES ONE
TO MEET FEDERAL REQUIREMENT
THAT THE STATE'S LEAD AGENCY
OVERSEE SBG. WHICH IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT HOLD A
PUBLIC HEARING ON ITS DRAFT
STATE PLAN FOR CS BG. AND TO IT
ALSO MEETS THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT THE STATE HOLD A
LEGISLATIVE HEARING ON CSP G.
EVERY THREE YEARS. THE SBG IS A
FEDERALLY FUNDED LOCALLY DRIVEN
ANTI POVERTY PROGRAMS HAS ROOTS
DATING BACK TO THE WAR ON
POVERTY OF THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
IN RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
RECEIVED ABOUT SIXTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS UNDER THE CS BG PROGRAM.
THESE FUNDS ARE USED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT ARE DEVELOPED IN
OFFERED IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO
COMMUNITY NEED. LOCAL ENTITIES
WERE REQUIRED TO MEET PROGRAM
AND FISCAL STANDARDS ARE GIVEN
THE FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE
THE TYPE OF SERVICES THEY ARE
MOST NEEDED WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. CSP E. G. FUNDS AN
ARRAY OF SERVICES RANGING FROM
MEETING THE BASIC HUMAN NEED
FOR FOOD TO MORE COMPLEX NEED.
LIKE EXITING FROM OR AVOIDING
HOMELESSNESS. ADDITIONALLY THE
FLEXIBILITY OF CSP G. ALLOWS.
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES TO BE NIMBLE
DURING A CRISIS. FOR EXAMPLE CS
BG FUNDS WERE USED TO RESPOND
IN REAL TIME TO THE NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT RECENTLY HIT
CALIFORNIA. DURING WHICH THE
SBG FUNDS WERE USED TO PROVIDE
FOOD SHELTER AND OTHER BASIC
NECESSITIES WELL MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE JOINING THE
BENEFITS OF A THRIVING ECONOMY.
POVERTY POSSESS PERSIST FOR
MANY OTHERS SADLY CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THREE STATES TYPE FOR
HIGHEST POVERTY RATE IN THE
COUNTRY. WE SURE THAT RANKING
WITH FLORIDA AND LOUISIANA.
ACCORDING TO SOME STIMATES.
ALMOST TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA LIVE IN DEEP POVERTY
FIVE MILLION LIVE AT THE
POVERTY LINE AND SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION ARE LIVING NEAR
POVERTY. THIS MEANS FOURTEEN
POINT ONE MILLION OR THIRTY SIX
POINT FOUR PERCENT. OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING AT OR
NEAR THE POVERTY LINE.
ADDITIONALLY WITH ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. CALIFORNIA HAD
THE LARGEST HOMELESS POPULATION
IN THE COUNTRY IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THESE NUMBERS ARE
TROUBLING AND I AM ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED WITH THE IMPACT OF
DEEP POVERTY ON OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR OLDER ADULTS. THUS I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING MORE
ABOUT HOW LOCAL COMMUNITY
ACTION AGENCIES ARE RESPONSIVE
TO COMMUNITY NEED AND HOW THE-DEPARTMENT WORKS TO SUPPORT
THOSE EFFORTS WHILE ALSO
OVERSEEING PROPER
ADMINISTRATION. OF PRECIOUS
FEDERAL DOLLARS. IN PARTICULAR
I AM INTEESTED IN HEARING MORE
ABOUT HOW COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES ARE RESPONDING TO THE
HOUSING CRISIS NATURAL
DISASTERS THE NEEDS OF MIGRANT
FARM WORKERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
ONE OH NINE INDIAN TRIBES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY I LIKE TO HEAR HOW
CHANGES IN FEDERAL POLICIES
REGARDING PUBLIC CHARGE ARE
IMPACTING LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. I'D LIKE TO BUY MY
COLLEAGUES. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HEIRS TO OFFER HER REMARKS AND
THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT
UP TO OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR FELLOW. CALIFORNIA'S
POVERTY RATE IS OF GREAT
CONCERN TO THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A THRIVING ECONOMY AND
THEY WERE TIED CENTERED PHOTO
MENTIONED. FOR THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATE IN THE COUNTRY IS
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE
CALIFORNIA FACES A NUMBER OF
COMPLEX FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO POVERTY IN THE STATE
INCLUDING LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. HIGH RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND HUNGER HUNGER
AMONG SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS MY
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE
INTRODUCED A NUMBER OF BILLS
AIMED AT ADDRESSING AND
ALLEVIATING. THE CONDITIONS OF
POWER POVERTY ESPECIALLY AMONG
CHILDREN AND SENIORS BUT
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE THAT CAN BE
DONE AND THAT'S WHY I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM TODAY'S
PANELISTS. MOST ESPECIALLY
THOSE FROM SAN BERNARDINO. THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
IS A VERSATILE SOURCE OF
FEDERAL FUNDING THE PROVIDES A
DIRECT AND IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN POVERTY.
I AM INTERESTED TO LEARN HOW
YOUR ORGANIZATIONS HAVE USED
THESE FUNDS TO RESPOND TO THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE TO HEAR
HOW CS BG FUNDS HAVE BEEN USED
TO RESPOND TO NATURAL DISASTERS.
I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
YOU COUNTY SUCH AS WILD FIRES
AND EARTHQUAKES HOW CS BG FUNDS
FACILITATE GREATER ACCESS TO
FOOD AMONG VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WE'LL BE HEARING
FOR SAM TO DINO. AND WHETHER
CSP G. FUNDS HAVE BEEN USED TO
PREPARE COMMUNITIES FOR THE
UPCOMING CENSUS SOMETHING THAT
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO US HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. AND ALSO HOW
CSP G. FUNDS CAN BE USED TO
MEET NEEDS THAT ARE OTHERWISE
ON MATT. MY OTHER ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS SUCH AS CAL WORKS AND
CAL FRESH. AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO A ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE IMPORTANT WORK
ACCOMPLISHED USING THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
AND HOW THE LEGISLATURE. CAN
SUPPORT THE INCREDIBLE WORK YOU
ALL ARE DOING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCTION. THERE IS A THANK
YOU VERY MUCH US SENATOR ARE
TAUGHT AND ALSO MEMBER RAY S.
AND MY COLLEAGUES I AM ONE
EXCITED ABOUT THIS HEARING TO
WHEN I WAS THE I WAS A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY COMMUNITY ACTION
BOARD CHAIR. UP OR CD BG FOR
MAYBE NINE YEARS OF LOS ANGELES-COUNTY WE HAD A VERY ROBUST
BUDGET AT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR FIVE TWO WAS DISTRICTS. IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
KNOW QUITE WELL WHAT THOSE
FUNDS WERE GEARED TO AND HOW IT
REALLY CHANGE AND HELP CHANGE
THE SUBJECT OF PEOPLE IN THE
GRASS ROOTS LEVEL NOW BEING IN
THIS POSITION AND YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT AND- BEING PART OF
THIS COMMITTEE. A COMMUNITY
SERVICE BLOCK GRANT FUNDS FOR
THE STATE I'M PARTICULARLY
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT WE CAN
DO BETTER BECAUSE THERE ARE YOU
KNOW THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE NO
MATTER HOW MUCH MONEY WE
GETTING. OUT I KNOW THAT THE
FEDERAL BUDGETS ARE CONTINUE TO
DWINDLE THE NUMBERS ARE AND
NEVER THE SAME AS A USED TO BE
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN ONE STEP
UP TO THE PLATE TO TRY TO HELP
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
AMONG US IN CALIFORNIA SO I'M
LOOKING VERY. I'M FOR TO THE
ROBUST CONVERSATIONAL IMPORTANT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AS. AS YOU
PROVIDING PRESIDE OVER THIS
JOINT HEARING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH UP AT THIS TIME ALL
GO HEAD INVITE THE FIRST PANEL
UP WE HAVE LA NAY STAY OUT. OF.
OKAY I APOLOGIZE SO JASON
WEMBLEY AND AT TONY MCKENNON
BRENDA CALLAHAN JOHNSON. ISN'T
THAT LIKE TO GO TO. SO WE WILL
HAVE THE PANELISTS PRESENT THE
PREPARED REMARKS AND THEN OPEN
IT UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING
UP PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
THE ORGANIZATION AND PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN YOUR FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WHEN YOU ARE
READY. IS ON NOW OKAY J.
SOMEONE THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE DEPARTMENT
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR TANO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAY AS IN MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEES. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT STATE
PLAN. AND TO SHARE OUR EFFORTS
TO MAXIMIZE. PRO RESOURCES
REDUCE POVERTY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AS I MENTIONED
I'M J. SIMPLY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF CST. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF DIRECTORS THOUSAND
CAME DOWN WITH AN ALMOST LAST
NIGHT AND APOLOGIZES FOR NOT
BEING ABLE TO MAKE TODAY'S
HEARING. CST MISSION IS REDUCE
POVERTY BY LEADING THE
DEVELOPMENT AND COORDINATION OF
EFFECTIVE AND INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THE DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTERS FUNDING TO HELP LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS ACHIEVE AND
MAINTAIN ECONOMIC SECURITY.
MEET THEIR HOME ENERGY NEEDS
AND WE DO SO UTILITY COSTS TO
ENERGY EFFICIENCY UPGRADES AND
CLEAN ACCESS RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE AMONG
OTHERS. THE FEDERAL AND LOW
INCOME HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. AND THE STATE'S CAP
AND TRADE FUNDED LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM WHICH
SERVES MULTI FAMILY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND FORMER OCCUR
HOUSEHOLDS. AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT DOES NEED TO COMMIT
TO MINISTER THE CSP G. WE WORK
WITH NONPROFIT THAT AND LOCAL
COMMUNITY OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THESE INCLUDE COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES MICROS AND SEES A
FARMWORKER AGENCIES AND NATIVE
AMERICAN INDIAN ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS FUNDING SOURCES FLEXIBLE.
IN THAT CAN BE SPENT ON A
VARIETY OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS SPECIFIC TO THE NEEDS
OF THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
AND THE UNIQUE REQUIREMENTS IS
THAT ORGANIZATIONS ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE TRY PART GOVERNING
BOARDS COMPRISE OF LOW INCOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IN ADDITION
TO PRIVATE SECTOR AND PUBLIC
OFFICIALS OR THEIR DESIGNEES.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THE FUNDING
HE'S LOCAL AGENCY MUST DEVELOP
AND SUBMIT AND NEEDS ASSESSMENT
INFORMED BY SURVEYS PUBLIC-FORMS AND THE DIRECT
INVOLVEMENT FROM LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN THE PLANNING. AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO BE DELIVERED IN
THAT COMMUNITY. IN THESE
ASSESSMENTS ARE CONDUCTED EVERY
TWO YEARS ESTIMATES OF
APARTMENT AS PART OF EACH IT
AGENCIES LOCAL COMMUNICATION
PLAN. THE PLAN ADDRESS THE
MEDIA ISSUES IMPACTING THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. OF
CALIFORNIANS COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDE QUANTITATIVE AND
QUALITATIVE. DATA THAT INFORM
THE SERVICE DELIVERY STRATEGIES
OF EACH AGENCY. IN ADDITION THE
LOCAL PLANT CONTRIBUTE TO THE
OVERALL STATE PLAN IN THE
DRESSING FEDERALLY MANDATED
PROGRAM ASSURANCES THAT THE
STATE MUST IT HERE TOO. BY
SHOWING HOW THE USE OF FUNDS
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS MOST VULNERABLE.
THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES A
STATE PLAN INCLUDE FOSTERING A
CULTURE OF COLLABORATION IN THE
INNOVATION ACROSS THE STATE.
AND LOCAL ENTITIES BY FOCUSING
ON A CLIENT CENTERED WHOLE
PERSON APPROACH THE HELP
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S COST
CRISIS TO SEVERAL TARGETED
INITIATIVES INCLUDING CONTINUUM
OF CARE SERVICES FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
DISASTER PERFECT. SORRY THAT'S
A PREPAREDNESS IN RECOVERY
ASSISTANCE THE TRESSES FOOD
DISTRIBUTION. IN CALIFORNIA
GIRL INCOME TAX CREDIT
AWARENESS OF FREE TAX
PREPARATION SERVICES. IN
ADDITION FOCUSING ON ACTIONABLE
DATA TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES THAT
SUPPORT THE REDUCTION IN POWER
THE FOR ONE OF THE POPULATIONS.
AND ESTABLISHING AND
MAINTAINING NEW TRAINING AND
SUPPORT PROGRAMS ASSISTING
EXCELLENCE TO HIGHLY SKILLED
WORKFORCE AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL. WE'RE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE LOCAL AGENCIES HERE TODAY
TO TELL YOU ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
THE MINISTER AND THE SUCCESSES
THEY- THEY'VE HAD IS THE WORK
TO BUILD A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
OF HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT
MANY LOCAL AGENCIES AND HAVE
WITNESSED FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT
THEIR INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY AND
NEIGHBORHOOD BASED IN THE
STATES HAVE MADE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S IN THE- I KNOW
THAT YOU'LL ENJOY HEARING
DIRECTLY FROM THEM AS WELL. NOW
LIKE TO BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE KEY INFORMATION ABOUT
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK
GRANT. THIS YEAR CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED OVER SIXTY THREE
MILLION SEES PRETTY FUNDING.
THESE FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED IN
THE COOK ACCORDANCE TO STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW. AND ALLOCATION
TO DETERMINE BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME LIVING
WITH THESE WITHIN EACH COUNTY
IN THE STATE. 90% THE FUNDS
GOES DIRECTLY TO LOCAL AGENCY.
INCLUDING STATE PLAN IS THE
THAT PROVIDES A GLIMPSE OF THE
GREAT WORK THE LOCAL AGENCIES
DO EVERY DAY TO SUPPORT. LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS ON THE ROAD
TO ECONOMIC STABILITY. THE
ABILITY. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS THE
DEPARTMENT REPORTS OUT
CONSISTENT STICKS TO FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA THROUGH A
NETWORK OF LOCAL AGENCIES
REPORTED. OVER ONE MILLION
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND NOW
COMES ALONG COMPETE TO SPEND
THE CALIFORNIA. THIS INCLUDES
SERVING 200-600-0021 SIXTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CHILDREN. UNDER
SEVEN NINE THOUSAND SENIORS.
SIXTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AT FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH A LOT. WHO
LACKED HEALTH INSURANCE. THESE
SERVICES NOW COMES INCLUDE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE SERVICES
WHERE SEVENTY THOUSAND LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
TEMPORARY SHELTER. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PLACEMENT. OF FICTION
FORECLOSURE PREVENTION. UTILITY
PAYMENT. ASSISTANCE OR HOME
WEATHERIZATION SERVICES.
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES WHICH
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE THE
BARRIERS TO INITIAL CONTINUES
EMPLOYMENT AND ALMOST EIGHTEEN
OUTCOMES SUCH AS A CAR THE JOB.
INCREASE THEIR EARNING FOR
CHIEF LIVING WAGE EMPLOYMENT
AND BENEFITS. EDUCATION IN
COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT SKILL THE
SERVICES WERE NINETY THOUSAND
CHILDREN YOUTH AND PARENTS
INCREASE SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE
IMPROVE LITERACY AND SCHOOL
READINESS AND THE RICH ARE HOME
ENVIRONMENTS. CONDITION TWENTY
MILLION MEALS AND FOOD PARCELS
WE DISTRIBUTE TO FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS IN NEED DURING
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. OF THE
REMAINING 10% OF THE CCG
FUNDING 5% IS DISCRETIONARY
WHICH INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
DISASTER RELIEF EFFORTS
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
ACTUAL PARTNERSHIP. AND OTHER
INNOVATIVE FOR TARGETED
INITIATIVES THE REMAINING 5% IS
USED BY THE STATE FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND OVERSIGHT
AND TO FURTHER DEVELOP.
PRODUCTIVE STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS TO DO A DRESS GAPS
IN SERVICE AS WE MOVE TOWARD A
CLIENT. CENTERED WHOLE PERSON
APPROACH TO OUR WORK. ESPN CCG
AGENCIES ARE TAKING A LEAD ROLE
IN BRINGING THE BENEFITS OF THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. WELL
PARTNERING WITH OTHER PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE PARTNERS TO
INCREASE AWARENESS OF THE
FEDERAL AND STATE CREDITS.
WHICH ARE SOME OF THE MOST
POWERFUL TOOLS FOR A LIFTING
LOW INCOME PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY. SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
CSC HAS LED THE REDUCING
POVERTY WORKGROUP ACCORDING
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE EFFORTS TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF. EITC
CLAIMS. THROUGH THESE EFFORTS
SEIZE THE AS PART IN WITH TH
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TOWARD. TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANT FUNDS
BETWEEN THE BASE EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS. TO INCREASE
AWARENESS OF THE KELLY I. T. C.
AND SUPPORT TAX PREPARATION.
ASSISTANCE FOR LOW INCOME TAX
FILERS. WITH GAVIN NEWSOM IN
THE LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURE'S
SIGNIFICAN SPENCER CALORIE HE
ITC THIS YEAR'S CST. AS
PARTNERS ARE MORE COMMITTED
THAN EVER TO ENSURING THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIANS. THAT ARE IN
THIS IMPORTANT SOURCE CAN CLAIM
IT. THAT THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
EVERY LOW AT EVERY LEVEL
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
SEIZE BG. AND SEES THE IS
COMMITTED TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE
AND EFFORT TO BUILD A- A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. BY WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS WE CAN SURE
THEY EACH CALIFORNIA SIR BYE
SEE SPECIES SCENES A WHOLE
PERSON. AND THAT WELL ROUNDED
DATA DRIVEN SERVICES MEET THEIR
NEEDS AS THEY NAVIGATE AND NEW
PATH. TOWARD ECONOMIC SECURITY.
THIS IS COMMITTED TO ENSURING
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES OF A
STRONG LEADERSHIP A
PARTNERSHIP. NEED TO WHETHER
ANY CHALLENGES THAT MAY LAY
AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT TO SEE
SPEECH THE STATE PLAN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ON GOING
SUPPORT THE CSPC PROGRAM. I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. TWENTY
MACULA DEJECTED DIRECTOR FOR
THE- CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
ACTION PARTNERSHIP ASSOCIATION.
THAT'S A MOUTHFUL WE CALL THAT
CAL KAPPA. THIS BATTERY GOES
DEAD IS NOT A. NONE CHAIRPERSON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR OBVIOUS REASONS THEY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE CANNOT
HAPPEN NO WORK CONSISTS OF
FIFTY EIGHT COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES AND OTHER AFFILIATED
MEMBERS THAT SERVE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ACROSS THE
CITY CALIFORNIA. IN CALIFORNIA
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
IN THEIR FAMILIES EACH YEAR
BETWEEN HELP FROM COMMUNITY
ACTION TO PROVIDE BASIC NEEDS
FOR THEIR FAMILIES OBTAIN JOBS
ESTABLISH A PHONE TO RECEIVE
EDUCATION. SO THEY CAN EXIT
POVERTY FOR GOOD. COMMUNITY
ACTION IS NOT JUST A SAFETY
NET. IT CREATES OPPORTUNITY AND
BUILD HEALTHY COMMUNITIES IT
FINDS UNMET NEEDS INCREASE
LOCAL SOLUTIONS TO LOCAL
PROBLEMS. OUR NETWORK HELPS
START SMALL BUSINESSES BILLS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND TRAINS A
SKILLED WORKERS. BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE WHEN PEOPLE THRIVE OUR
COMMUNITIES THRIVE. CAMPUS
MISSION IS TO ADVANCE ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO HELP
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
PEOPLE ACHIEVE SELF SUFFICIENCY
BY GENERATING QUALITY TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. FOR
AGENCIES DEVELOPING AND
PROMOTING A TRANSFER WITH A
PUBLIC POLICY. AND PRACTICES
AND BUILDING AWARENESS OF
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS OUR STATE
FOR WAR A GLOBAL ECONOMY. ONE
OF THE MAIN FOCUSES OF CAL
KAPPA IS TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR AGENCIES WE
REFER TO THIS IS T. AND T. A.
RTG PRIMARY SPORTS COMPLIANCE
WITH THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
BLOCK GRANTS ORGANIZATIONAL
STANDARDS FOR A PRIVATE.
NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC AGENCIES
THAT ARE APPROVED FOR FUNDING
TO SEE SB G. TJ ACTIVITIES ALSO
SATISFY ADDITIONAL ANSWERING
NEEDS. FOR THE SAME AGENCIES
AND AREAS INCLUDING SHALL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. MANAGER
AND LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT TEAM
BUILDING AND CUSTOM TRAINING
PROGRAMS AS WELL. OR TNT IS
FUNDED BY A COMBINATION OF
GRANTS DISCRETIONARY FUNDING
FROM CSD CAM FEE FOR SERVICE
WITH THE AGENCIES PAY. SOME
PORTION FOR THE TRAINING THAT
THEY RECEIVED. THE BOOK OF THE
TEEN AND HERE TALK APPLE
PERFORMS SUPPORTS THE
TRIPARTITE BOARDS WHO UNIQUE
WAY OF HAVING YOUR BOARD
LEADERSHIP THAT INVOLVES THOSE
THAT ARE RECEIVING THE SERVICES
AND THE DECISIONS. ABOUT HOW
THE SERVICES FOR OUR PROVIDED
IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. MY
TRAINING THE STRAIGHT PARTY
BOYS WE EDGE ENABLE SOUND
STRATEGIC PLANNING AND WE
EXPANDED OPTION OF WHAT'S
CALLED THE ROMA MODEL AND ROMA
STANDS FOR RESULTS ORIENTED
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY. SURE
AGENCIES ARE LOOKING TO BE SURE
THEY ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE
WITH THE PROGRAMS. OKAY. AND
THOSE THAT ARE OPERATING PUBLIC
AND NONPROFIT AGENCIES. WITH
SUPPORT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT CAL CAP HAS
LAUNCHED A NEW PROGRAM CALLED
THE CAL CAP ACADEMY. WE USE THE
INTERNET BASED LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT HELPS US
TO TRACK THE LEARNING AND THE
TRAINING FOR ALL WERE AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE. AND
THROUGHOUT OUR ENTIRE NETWORK.
YEAH BUT I CAN ONLY HOUSES E.
LEARNING COURSES AND PROVIDES
ACCESS TO INSTRUCTOR LED
COURSES ALL AROUND THE STATE.
ON AND ON AND ON DEMAND SYSTEM.
BECAUSE THIS CAR CAP OR CATTERY
IS INTERNET BASED AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL OTHER LARGE STATE
AGENCIES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES THAT ARE ALSO MOVING
INTO THIS. INTERNET RESTAURANT
BUT BASS TRAINING WE'RE ABLE TO
COLLABORATE AND TO BUILD OUR
EXPERTISE WITH LAYERS. CONTENT
CREATORS ABLE TO DESIGN SURE
COURSES THAT ARE APPLICABLE TO
OTHER NETWORKS AND AS THIS
LIBRARY OF LEARNING ASSETS
GROWS LEARNERS WILL BE ABLE TO
FOLLOW. PRESCRIBED LEARNING
PLANS. THAT THIS ROLE BASED
CURRICULUM CAN BE CONSISTENT
TAILORED COURSES TO SUPPORT
EACH OF OUR AGENCIES AND
MEETING THEIR MISSION. THE
MEMBERSHIP IN THIS ACADEMY IS
OPEN ALL REMEMBER AGENCIES AND
BY REQUEST ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE. WE HAVE
OUR NETWORK I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PREVIOUS SUPPORT
OF THIS YEAR'S BG ENERGY TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE ROLE OF
THE SUPPORT AND FUNDING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
CONTATO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY AS
AN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS BRENDA
CALLAHAN JOHNSON AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE MERCED COUNTY
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCY. AS
WELL AS THE PAST PRESIDENT OF
KAPPA KAPPA THROUGH MAY OF THIS
YEAR. IT IS AN HONOR TO JOIN
YOU TODAY AND SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. ALTHOUGH
OUR NAMES AREN'T THE SAME AND
SOME OF US ARE PRIVATE
NONPROFIT WHILE OTHERS ARE ARMS
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT. OUR
MISSION IS TO POSITIVELY IMPACT
POVERTY IN OUR COMMUNITIES
EASING THE PLIGHT OF THE POOR
AND RAISING THEM OUT OF THE
RANKS OF POVERTY. BECAUSE OF
THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND THE FIFTY EIGHT
THE SBG ENTITY STATEWIDE. WE
HAVE MADE LONG STRIDES TOWARDS
HELPING THE MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES LIVE BETTER
LIVES AND REALIZE THEIR DREAMS.
THERE ARE FIFTY EIGHT CS BG
ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
REPRESENTING EVERY CORNER OF
THIS HUGE STATE. CST TWO
DOLLARS FOR THE FUNDS THAT BIND
US THAT GUY YES AND THEY GIVE
US THE FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND
TO EACH COMMUNITY IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. MAKING OUR
SERVICES MORE TARGETED AND
IMPACTFUL TO THOSE THAT WE
SERVE. THE FACT THAT A HUGE
MAJORITY OF OUR AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES SINCE NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE. POINTS TO OUR
FLEXIBILITY AND ABILITY TO
ADAPT TO THE EVER CHANGING
FACES OF THE POOR IN OUR STATE.
WHEN I FIRST STARTED IN
COMMUNITY ACTION IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE FIVE MONTHS OUT OF
COLLEGE. I TAUGHT A CLASS ON
CANNING AND PRESERVING FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES. WE REGULARLY
DISTRIBUTED WOOD IN THE WINTER.
OBVIOUSLY TIMES CHANGE NOW
FREED IS CHEAPER TO BUY IN THE
STORE AND WOOD BURNING ISN'T
OPTIMAL FOR OUR OUR AIR QUALITY.
CHANGE THAT THAT SCARE US AND
EXCITE SAYS. TO GIVE EXAMPLE TO
WHAT WE DO ACROSS THE STATE
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCIES ARE
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IF NOT THE
LEADERS ON THE ISSUES OF
HOMELESSNESS RUNNING HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEMS
TO TRACK DATA ON EVERY HOMELESS
PERSON RECEIVING SERVICES AND
SHELTERS AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. THE
DATA WE COLLECT GUIDES ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES ON PROJECTS AND
PRIORITIES WHEN DEALING WITH
THEIR HOMELESS POPULATIONS. THE
SBG DOLLARS GIVE US THE
FLEXIBILITY TO TRY NEW IDEAS
AND EXPAND PROGRAMS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE WHEN COMPARED TO
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES THAT
MIGHT LIMIT OUR ABILITY TO BE
SO FLEXIBLE. ONE EXAMPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY AND SINCE BUILDING
YOU SEE MORE SAD HOUSING
HOUSING AVAILABILITY HAS
PLUMMETED 21% AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOUSING THE HOMELESS IS
ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT WHEN COMPETITION
FOR HOUSING IS MAINSTREAM
WORKERS AND STUDENTS. WITH THE
SB TWO DOLLARS WE HAVE NOT ONLY
BEEN ABLE TO ADD A POSITION OF
THE HOUSING ADVOCATE TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL LANDLORDS
BUT WALK THE CUSTOMER THROUGH
THE HOUSING PROCESS AND ACT AS
A CONTACT FOR THE LANDLORDS YOU
MAY BE EXPERIENCING PROBLEMS
WITH THEIR TENANTS. WE HAVE
ALSO BEEN ABLE TO EXTEND STAYS
THE NAVIGATION CENTERS AND
SHELTERS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
STILL WAITING TO BE HOUSED.
STATE AND FEDERAL PROGRAMS HAVE
STRICT LIMITS ON HOW LONG
INDIVIDUALS COULD STAY IN THESE
PROGRAMS WHICH DOESN'T ALWAYS
CORRELATE WITH THE NEED. THE
SBG ADDRESSES THAT NEED. THIS
IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
FLEXIBILITY OF CS BG BUT OTHER
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
COULD FILL YOUR DAYS WITH
SIMILAR STORIES OF HOW
ESSENTIAL CFE GS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. MOST RECENTLY MANY
OF THE COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES AND SPECIALLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS THE STATE BY OUT
WORKERS. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO USE
THE SBG DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
MEANING LOCATIONS OFFICE
EQUIPMENT. MARKETING CAMPAIGNS
AND CONTACT POINTS FOR
IMMIGRATION AND NATURALIZATION
SERVICES. INCLUDING DOCTOR RE
CERTIFICATIONS AND FINES FOR
PEOPLE TO RECERTIFY. A SERVICE
THAT WAS NOT NEEDED AND ON OUR
COMMUNITY AS EARLY AS THREE
YEARS AGO. CHANGE CAME QUICKLY
AND WE ADOPTED. THE SBG FUNDED
AGENCY SERVED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
LAST YEAR AND INSERTED OVER
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING AND A CALIFORNIA
THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS WITH
PRIVATE FUNDERS FEDERAL DOLLARS
I LEVERAGING OF EITHER SEE SB
G. RESOURCES. THE F. B. G. AS
THE SEED MONEY THAT ALLOWS US
TO MAKE ONE DOLLAR AND TEN NINE
DOLLARS THROUGH COLLABORATION
INNOVATION AND A TRUE BELIEF
THAT WE CAN ALWAYS DO BETTER
FOR THOSE IN NEED. WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF CS BG NOT ONLY IN
THE STATE BUT IN YOUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND I WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT
UP. FOR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF ALL. START
WITH OUR OUR- CULTURE HERE. YES.
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT I'VE SEEN
THROUGH YOU NEVER HEARING THAT
WE HAVE IS THAT THEY'RE GREAT
PROGRAMS BUT THE OUTREACH IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT KELLY I TO
SEE IS A GREAT EXAMPLE THAT WE
HAVE THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT BUT IF THE COMMUNITY
DOESN'T KNOW ABOUT IT THEN IT
DOESN'T MATTER THE MONEY IS PUT
INTO THIS FUND. WHAT SPECIFIC.
SUCCESS STORIES DO YOU HAVE
ABOUT COMMUNITY OUTREACH FOR
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED
THROUGH CSP G. WELL I CAN.
OFFER THE EXAMPLE OF THAT
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT OUR REACH SO AS I
MENTIONED SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
THE DEPARTMENT IS WORKING M.
HAS FORMED A STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO PROMOTE GREATER
AWARENESS TO THE CALIFORNIA AND
FEDERAL BOTH BOTH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GUARANTEE COME TAX
CREDITS AND TAX PREPARATION
SERVICES. AND AS A RESULT OF
THOSE EFFORTS WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE OF REALIZE AN INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE CLAIMED THOSE CREDITS
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO DO SO AND
IN THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE
FIND OUR COMMUNITY BASED THE
CONNECTED TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY SERVE AND PROVIDE
EFFECTIVE OUTREACH TO AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK WE'VE SEEN
THE SUCCESS AND IT UP TURN OF
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN CLAIMING.
THAT VALUABLE RESOURCE I WILL
TELL YOU THE DECEMBER DINO THAT
IT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL THE
OUTRAGE OF FOR THE KELLY I TO
SEE I'VE SEEN THEM IN THE
COMMUNITY AFTER THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD CAME OUT AT THAT TIME
IT WAS FIONA MAMA CAME OUT WITH
THE BIG BUS AT THE COMPUTER SET
UP AND DID A LOT OF WORK HERE
SORRY. THE OUT REACH FOR ME IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS IS MAKING SURE
THAT WE GET THE SERVICES AND
THE FUNDS TO THE PEOPLE. WHO
MOST NEED THEM. THANK YOU FOR
RESPONDING. SENATOR PAN. THANK
YOU THINK IT'S VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE IT THE PRESENTATION
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING FOR THE
FLATTENED BLOCK GRANT STATE
PLAN WHICH WE DO EVERY TWO
YEARS CORRECT. YES FOR FIRST
AND BASICALLY HAD TO FORGIVE
THE BACKGROUND INFORMATION SO.
I WAS LOOKING AT FIRST OF ALL
PEOPLE SERVICED I DID NOTE THAT
AT LEAST ON THE SHEET I AVE
ACTUALLY DOESN'T BREAK OUT WITH
TINO SO I AM TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. OUR WHO ARE SERVING IN
TERMS OF OUR REP ETHNIC RACIAL.
HE'S I WOULD POINT OUT I MEAN
WE DO HAVE 19% OTHER SO IT'S
HARD TO FIGURE OUT LIKE TO THE
OTHER IS AND PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
REPORT. AS A MEMBER OF THE API
CAUCUS I WOULD MAKE NOTED THAT
ASIANS ARE ONLY 5% OTHER WERE
16% OF POPULATION AND I KNOW WE
HAVE. TREMENDOUS INCOME
DISPARITIES IN THE API
POPULATION SICKLY. IN OUR
PACIFIC ISLAND AGREES BUT ALSO
AMONG ASIAN COMMUNITIES SO. I
GUESS ONE QUESTION IS WHY ARE
WE SERVING SO FEW API. YEAH
THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW THAT'S
SOMETHING I DON'T HAVE A IN IN
THE MEDIA ANSWER FOR PRESS
SOMETHING COULD RESEARCH IF
SOMEONE COULD PLEASE. GET BACK
TO ME ON THAT SO AND ALSO AGAIN
I MAKE NOTE THAT LATINOS ITEM
ON THE LIST SO I CAN'T FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE DOING WITH THAT
AS WELL SO IN TERMS OF
REPORTING IT COULD BE GOOD FOR
US TO HAVE THE KIND OF DATA LET
US KNOW. WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
HOW WE MIGHT WANT TO RE DIRECT
I REALIZE THAT THIS MAY BE ALL
SELF REPORTED DATA SO THAT HAS
ITS OWN CHALLENGES PEOPLE MAY
NOT WANT TO BUT STILL IT BE
GOOD TO HAVE A BREAK DOWN OF
THAT THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD
WAS. NOW IF YOU DO LISTS THAT I
DO LISTA THESE ACTIVITIES. AS
WELL I HEAR IT'S THIS WE HAVE
SOME EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE GET
SERVICES THE LIVER AND A SO IN
TERMS OF THE VALUATION SO FOR
EXAMPLE. IN UNDER INCOME AND
ASSET BUILDING SERVICES AND
AGAIN YOU HAVE SEVERAL OF THEM
THE ONLY THIS IS SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED BUT- ONLY TWENTY FOUR
ARE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
SAID THEY INCREASE OR SAVINGS.
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND PROXIMALLY RECEIVE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE SERVICES.
ONLY SEVENTY THOUSAND WHICH IS
LESS THAN HALF A RECEIPT OF
RACIAL TERROR AND SO FORTH. SO
I'M TRYING TO GET A BETTER
HANDLE ON THE OUTCOMES
ABDULAZEEZ ARE CHALLENGING
PROBLEMS RIGHT CELL AND I MEAN
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE CRITICAL
AND SAYING THAT WELL. HE HELPED
LESS THAN HALF OF THEM I MEAN
THEIR CHILDREN AS PROBLEMS BUT
IN TERMS OF THE EVALUATION. I
THINK IT BE HELPFUL TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT. AND BETTER
REFLECT. BOTH WHAT'S BEING DONE
AND THE REASONS FOR THE
OUTCOMES THAT WERE ACHIEVED ANY
AYE SO I HAVE A HARD SENSE. TO
GET TO FEEL WHETHER IS THAT
GOOD ENOUGH NOT GOOD ENOUGH IT
CETERA SO. IS THERE SOME PLACE
THAT THERE'S A REPORT THAT
ACTUALLY SAYS WELL THIS IS WHAT
WE'VE DONE AND THIS IS WHAT THE
EXPECTED OUTCOME WAS AND. WE
EITHER HIT THE MARKET WE DIDN'T
HIT THE MARK ON THOSE THINGS.
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT TO MENTION.
OKAY SO YOU KNOW IT'S THIS IS A
NEW REPORTING WE'RE WE'RE
MAKING THOSE DISTINCTIONS
BETWEEN SERVICES AND OUTCOMES
AND POOR OUTCOMES AND THE
NUMBER OF FOLKS SIR AND SO WHAT
WE CAN DO IS WE CAN GO AFTER
FOLLOWING THE HEARING I COULD
DO SOME FURTHER RESEARCH THIS
IF WE HAVE ANY INFORMATION THAT
COULD EXPLAIN SO WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AS HAVING A BETTER
DESCRIPTION OF YOUR EVALUATION
PLAN OF WHAT SORT REPORTS WE
EXPECT. BACK SO WE KNOW IT IT
IT AND I SHOULD I JUST IT ALSO
JUST SAY IT I MY BACKGROUND
ACTUALLY OF THE ONLY
PEDIATRICIAN I ACTUALLY WAS A
PROFESSOR AND TO ME THAT
ELEMENT AT UC DAVIS COMMUNITY
BUILDING IS SOMETHING THAT I
CARE A LOT ABOUT THIS TALK TO
MY STAFF AND I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE DID SO WHAT DOES
BLACK GRANT DOES WHAT YOU DO IS
RIGHT IN LINE WITH THAT SO IN
THAT SENSE IT OUT AND I WANT
YOU TO CONTINUE DOING IT OKAY
BUT I'M ALSO ASKING SOME THESE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I. WANT OF A
LITTLE BIT OF YOU KNOW WE WANT
TO STEP IT UP HERE A LITTLE BIT
AND REALIZE THAT THERE'S ALSO
FEDERAL GRANT YOU HAVE FEDERAL
CONSTRAINTS I KNOW THAT WHEN
YOU GO TO THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE PRIDE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH SOME OF THAT AS WELL
BUT I THINK THAT EIGHT SOME OF
THE LA I DO THINK THAT YOUR
AGENCY DOES AND CAN MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
OFTENTIMES OF SAMPLE THE STUDY
LOOKING AT WELL WHAT HAPPENS.
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN POVERTY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT RIGHT DISCUSS ALL THE
BACK TO YOU KNOW PRESENT
JOHNSON'S ACTUALLY SLIGHTLY
OLDER AND I AM THIS PROGRAM IT
STARTED BEFORE I WAS BORN IT'S
BUT IT REALLY WAS ABOUT FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE BILL DOES THAT
SOCIAL CAPITAL THE SODAS
LINKAGES BETWEEN PEOPLE AND-
THE FACT IS THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN POVERTY OFTEN HAVE FEWER
CONNECTIONS RIGHT AND IT'S ONE
OF THE ISSUES NOT OBVIOUSLY
THEY ALSO A FEW RESOURCES RIGHT
SO YOU WILL HAVE FEWER.
RESOURCES AND FEWER CONNECTIONS
SO EVEN. A. GET OUT SO EVEN IF
WE GIVE PEOPLE MORE RESOURCES.
THAT I ITSELF WILL BE HELPFUL
BUT MAY NOT NECESSARILY HELP
THEM AS MUCH AS WE CAN ALSO
BUILD THOSE CONNECTIONS NEXT.
WE WHAT I THINK AT LEAST MY
READING AS IS WHAT YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO HELP DID RIGHT
CRIES IT'S DO THAT SO I YOU
KNOW I WANT YOU TO BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL. AND I REALLY DID
WANT TO YEAH I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION.
I'M ALSO HOPING THAT WE CAN GET
A BIT MORE INFORMATION I ALSO
KNOW THIS IS A TWO YEAR EVERY
TWO YEARS SO MAYBE MY LAST
QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE ON IS
THAT SINCE THE LAST TWO YEARS
THE HEARING TWO YEARS AGO WHAT
HAVE WE LEARNED IN THIS TWO
YEARS THAT WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
DIFFERENT FOR THIS NEXT TWO
YEARS SO I'M NOT SURE I QUITE
HER I HEARD A LOT OF PRESENT.
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
PRESENTATION APPRECIATED ABOUT
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING SO I
LIKE TO KNOW IS WHAT IS IT THAT
YOU'VE LEARNED IN THE PAST TWO
pTO CHANGE WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
MOVING FOR TO. MAKE THIS
PROGRAM YOU BETTER MORE
EFFECTIVE. RIGHT SO. ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING AT TO IMPROVE
HIS. DATA COLLECTION AND
DEFINITELY YOUR- YOUR COMMENTS
OR ARE TIMELY. AND WE CAN
FACTOR THAT IN. WE HAVE BEEN IN
THE CONVERSATION WITH THE FEDS
ON. THIS ISSUE REPORTING AS A
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WE ARE
TRANSITIONING TO. A NEW METRICS
THAT WE'RE USING TO BETTER
QUANTIFY THE OUTCOMES OF THIS
IS B. T. PROGRAM. SO THAT'S
DEFINITELY A FOCUS IN IN TERMS
OF SERVICES AS EMPHASIZE IF
THEY PLAN. THIS ISSUE OF.
HOUSING THIS HOUSING CRISIS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DEFINITELY
EXPERIENCING. IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT'S FRONT AND
CENTER FOR MOST OF OUR
COMMITTEE ORGANIZATIONS. AND
THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT IS A
PRESSING ISSUE AND WILL BE
MOBILIZING TO ADDRESS IT. IN IN
DIFFERENT FORMS. OKAY THANK YOU
I WOULD JUST MAKE NOTE AND NOW
CERTAINLY DOES FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS IS A FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAM YOU NEED TO MEET
THOSE. I ALSO HOPE THOSE YOU'RE
LOOKING AT DATA COLLECTION AND
SO FORTH THINKING ABOUT. IN
ADDITION TO WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ONE AND I AM
INTERESTED AND YOU DON'T SPEND
ALL YOUR MONEY JUST ON DATA
COLLECTION. BUT THINK ABOUT
WHAT. KIND OF THINGS WE NEED TO
KNOW HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AS
WELL IN TRYING TO CONSTRUCT
YEAR DATA COLLECTION AND DATA
REPORTING AN EVALUATION. IN DO
YOU WANT TO ADD. YES I WOULD
AND WORKING HERE BUT I WANT TO
TALK TO THEM ABOUT DATA
COLLECTION AND OUTCOMES. YOU'D
YOU'D MENTIONED THAT THERE IS A
BROAD I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHO
WAS WITH THE BROAD. NUMBER WAS.
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND THEN THE OUTCOME
WAS. KNOWS THAT A CHIEF
TEMPORARY SHELTER AT HALF. WELL
THERE'S ANOTHER WAY TO LOOK AT
THAT WHICH IS SOMETIMES THE
BEST OUTCOME UNDER HOMELESS AND
HOUSING ASSISTANCE IS NOT. TO
RECEIVE TEMPORARY SHELTER.
SOMETIMESTHE BEST OUTCOME IS
TO STAY IN YOUR HOME. AND THOSE
NUMBERS ARE NOT RECORDED THERE
SHOULD. THE DATA COLLECTION WE
HAVE A DOESN'T ALWAYS REFLECT
ALL OF THE POSSIBLE OUTCOMES
THAT COULD COME UNDER THAT
BROADER HEADING. WE HAVE SO
PLEASE HELP. US HELP YOU BY
HELPING US BETTER UNDERSTAND
YOUR OUTCOMES THAT SO I SAID I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT IS REALLY
BAD RIGHT THESE ARE DIFFICULT
PROBLEMS SO. HAVING THAT
CONTEXT. AND EXPLANATION WOULD
BE A VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU.
NUMBER ARAMBULA. THANK YOU TO
HER TITLE AND- JUST TO PUT SOME
CONTEXT ON A FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
MANDATE TO HAVE BOTH THE
LEGISLATIVE HEARING OVER YOUR
FUNDING. AND AS SUCH WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT UR QUESTIONS
ARE BEING VERY DIRECTED INTO
BUT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK YOU ABOUT OUR LOCAL
PROGRAMS SO WHILE I CAN
APPRECIATE THAT THERE ARE FIFTY
EIGHT DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT
ARE WORKING MAYBE THERE ARE
SOME AGENCIES THAT. COULD DO
MORE WORK. I'M LUCKY THAT MY
SENATOR HAS ACTUALLY PLACED MY
MOTHER ON TO ONE OF THE
AGENCIES ON THE BOARD. THAT IS
BEFORE US HERE TODAY. YET I
FIND THAT YOUR MISSION AS CST
AS YOU WROTE IT IS TO FOSTER A
CULTURE OF COLLABORATION AND
INNOVATION. THAT'S A WHOLE
PERSON APPROACH. I STRUGGLE IS
WHATIF MY COUNTY IS NOT
PARTICIPATING IN WHAT WE KNOW
IS AN EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM
THAT'S WORKING. THAT WHOLE
PERSON CARES. IS THERE EVER AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US IN IN THESE
CONTRACTS THAT YOU CURRENTLY
HAVE WITH THE EEOC. TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR LOSSES ARE BEING
HEARD AT FRESNO COUNTY. THAT
WERE PARTICIPATING IN THE WHOLE
PERSON CARES PROGRAM THAT WE AS
A STATE OF PUT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES INTO THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR IT WOULD SEEM THAT YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND TEAM COULD
HELP TO MAKE THE CASE. FOR WHY
HOLD PERSON CARES IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH FOR MY COUNTY TO BE
PARTICIPATING IN MIKE BECAUSE
WHAT I FEEL THAT'S HAPPENING IS
WE'RE LEAVING MONEY ON THE
TABLE. OTHER COUNTIES ARE
UTILIZING AND MY COMMUNITY. AND
MEMBERS ARE ARE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN. AND SO I'D
LIKE SOME ASSISTANCE IF I CAN
FROM THIS GROUP SINCE WE ONLY
MEET EVERY TWO YEARS TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT BY TO SEE IF YOU CAN
HELP US. WITH THIS ASK THROUGH
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
FIGURE OUT WHY WE ARE NOT
PARTICIPATING CURRENTLY IN THE
WHOLE PERSON CARES PILOT
PROGRAM. AND HAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING. BECAUSE FOR SPENDING ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EOC. I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT TYPE
OF COLLABORATION THEY'RE DOING.
THAT'S MORE BENEFICIAL. THEN
APPLYING FOR THE WHOLE PERSON.
PROGRAM RIGHT SO. I'LL START
WITH THAT I DO WANT TO SAY A
COUPLE AT A BOYS ARE AT A GIRLS
IF I CAN BLOCK CORPORATE THE OF
THEY CAMPESINO THE CALIFORNIA
IS A WONDERFUL ORGANIZATION AS
WELL AS PROTEUS SOME OF THE
GROUPS THAT YOU'RE WORKING WITH
AND THE VALLEY DO GREAT WORK. I
CONTINUE TO LOOK TO THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS WHICH ARE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS AND MY COMMUNITY.
ESPECIALLY AS WE HAVE ISSUES
AND FEARS REGARDING PUBLIC
CHARGE IT'S IMPORTANT TO.
CONTINUE TO USE THOSE
RESOURCES. BUT I WANTED TO ASK
YOU TWO QUESTIONS IF I COULD.
THE FIRST IS REGARDING A TASK
FORCE THAT YOU GUYS HAVE A.
IT'S ON PAGE EIGHTEEN THE
HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES TASK
FORCE I WANT TO SEE IF YOU HAD
ANY UPDATES AND THE SECOND WAS
IN THE OVERVIEW THAT WE HAD.
REGARDING. THIS HEARING TODAY
CURRENTLY CSP G. IS. TO NOT.
THE ONLY BE FUNDED FOR THOSE
WHO ARE UNDER A 100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. IS THERE
A PARITY IS THERE ACTUALLY A
LEVEL THAT WOULD MAKE MORE
SENSE. IS IF THE STATE WAS
INTERESTED AND WILLING. I LOOK
TOWARDS THINGS LIKE MEDI CAL
WHICH HAD A 138% WHERE'S THERE
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY MAKES
LOGICAL SENSE. IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU GUYS HAVE THOUGHT
ABOUT AND WHAT WOULD THE COST
BE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT THAT'S
NOT INHERENTLY TIED TO THE
STATE PLAN BUT I DO WANT TO
JUST TAKE THAT. OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK THOSE TWO QUESTIONS WITH.
IT IS A OF FRESH FOR AS THE
FUNDING GOES NOT ONLY IS THAT
SOMETHING WE THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS A LOT
OF. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ESTABLISHED THAT RATE ON A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. AND WE HAVE ACTUALLY
TRIED A FEW TIMES TO MAKE SOME
INROADS. INTO GETTING.
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA TO MATCH THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION 110025% AND I'M NOT
BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
YEAH WE WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT
HAVING THAT HAPPEN TO BE PART
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING. PART OF
CAL CAP AS WELL AS TO A WORK AS
THE ADVOCACY ARM OF THE IN
NETWORK AND SO. THAT I GET TASK
WITH A LOT OF THAT STUFF. AND I
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU OR
WITH ANYONE ELSE IS INTERESTED
IN DOING THAT TO INSURE THAT WE
CAN. ALIGN STATE LEGISLATION
WITH FEDERAL LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD BE FUN TIME LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP OFFLINE ON THAT
SPECIFICALLY IF WE CAN. BUT
THEN IF WE COULD GET AN UPDATE
ON THAT TASK. APPRECIATE THAT
TOO. I'M SO AS FAR AS THE TASK
FORCE. I DON'T PARTICIPATE IN
IT DIRECTLY BUT- I DO KNOW THAT
I WE HAVE HAD INTEREST AT THE-
APARTMENT. IN EXPLORING HOW.
HEALTH CAN INTEGRATE INTO A LOT
OF THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING ON
OUR AND SHE PROGRAMS. BECAUSE
DEFINITELY THERE'S A DIRECT
ACCESS TO THE HOME. THE HOME WE
ABILITY ASIAN THAT OF THE OUR
PROGRAMS PROVIDE. AND NOT ONLY
FOCUSING ON ENERGY REDUCTION.
AND CLIMB. IN GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION. BUT ALSO CAN BE USED
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THE
LIVING CONDITIONS OF THOSE
HOMES. AND DOING IT IN A WAY
THAT WE CAN QUANTIFY WHAT THE
IMPACTS ARE. WHEN EXAMPLE AND
THERE'S BEEN SOME STUDIES THAT
HAVE BEEN UNDERTAKEN BY. PUBLIC
HEALTH TERMS OF A PILOT THAT.
THEY SHOULD SOME LIGHT ON ARE
THE PROGRAM'S ABILITY TO IMPACT
AIR QUALITY. AND PROVIDE AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS WITHIN THE
HOME. THAT COULD TO PROVIDE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR. YOUNG
CHILDREN DEALING WITH ASTHMA OR
OTHER. RESPIRATORY ISSUES. AND
THEN ALSO WITH. WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE AS IS OCCURRING IN OUR
STATE AREAS WHERE. THERE'S A
NEED FOR BETTER REGULATING OF
INDOOR AIR TEMPERATURES. WHERE
SOME OF ALL THE BALL THE BALL
POPULATION MEMBERS. YOU KNOW
CANNOT DEAL WITH. YOU KNOW
EXTREME HEAT OR EXTREME COLD AS
AN EXAMPLE. AND THEIR HOMES ARE
NOT EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE YOU
KNOW THAT. THEIR BASIC NEEDS OF
REGULATING THE INDOOR AIR
TEMPERATURE. SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE DEFINITELY. GIVEN
SOME THOUGHT TO INSPIRE
HEADING. AND THAT'S AN AREA OF
FOCUS RIGHT NOW FOR THE PART.
AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I MAY
CHAIRS. NOTS TO HIGHLIGHT THE
WORK OF. OUR CHAIR OF HUMAN
SERVICES THAT SHE'S DONE ON E.
I. T. C. AND- I TEN. WELL WE
HAVE MADE GREAT STRIDES. THIS
YEAR THERE IS STILL WORK TO BE
DONE AND. OUR ABILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL WORKING FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE TREATED
EQUALLY AND GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR A. I. T. C. IS
SOMETHING I HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION. CAN WORK ON
NEXT YEAR SO THAT YOUR
ORGANIZATION. CAN CONTINUE TO
HELP US WITHOUT WHICH- FUTURES.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM WHICH TO WORK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I DID WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON SOMETHING THE
DOCTOR PAN MENTIONED ABOUT
BUILDING WEALTH. IN THE
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS CAN IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE USED TO
HELP WITH FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS WITH DOWN PAYMENTS IS
THAT THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX
IS THAT. NOT PART OF THIS BOX.
FIVE MINUTES NOT NOT. NO I
PUSHED THE SENATE NOT ON OKAY.
SO IF I MEAN I GUESS THE BEST
WAY I WOULD DESCRIBE IT WOULD
BE A CATCH TWENTY TWO BECAUSE
WE'RE DEALING WITH PEOPLE THAT
ARE LIVING AT LESS THAN A 100%
OF POVERTY LEVEL. SO WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT ARE AT THAT LOW INCOME A
FAMILY OF FOUR THAT MAKES
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR EVEN WITH DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE IT WOULD NOT BE A
FAMILY THAT COULD SUSTAIN A
MORTGAGE AND THEY BARELY CAN
SUSTAIN SOMETIMES SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATION THAT AROUND SO WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE POPULATION.
KIND OF BY FEDERAL DESIGN THAT
IS SO LOW INCOME THAT NOT ONLY
OUR OUTCOMES HARDER BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THAT DOCTOR PAN MENTIONED
THAT THE I DON'T HAVE ANY
SAVINGS WELL YOU KNOW ONCE
PEOPLE GET A. B. I. T. C.
CREDIT IT JUST TRYING TO KEEP
THEM ABOUT WATER YOU KNOW THEY
PAY THEIR BACK TO P. JEANNIE
BELL OR THEIR BACK TO RANT
BECAUSE- THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY ON A MONTHLY BASIS TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. AND SO THEY'RE
CONSTANTLY MAKING A DECISION OF
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO PAY AND
SO HE I. T. C. I ALWAYS SAY
GIVE HIM SOME BREATHING ROOM.
SO THAT THEY CAN CATCH UP AND
MAYBE YOU KNOW NOT WORRY ABOUT
WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL IS GOING
TO COME FROM OR IF THE
LEVELLERS GONNA COME KNOCKING
SO IT'S A GREAT IDEA IT'S JUST
OUR PEOPLE ARE SO LOW INCOME
EVEN WITH THE DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE TEST SUSTAINING
MORTGAGE IN ALMOST ANY. COUNTY
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD PROBABLY BE
A LEAP OF FAITH. AND IS IT
SOMETHING THAT IF ONE OF THE
PROGRAM ONE OF YOUR- ANTES WERE
TO FIND A WAY TO HELP ITH THIS
AND OF COURSE THEN THE PAYMENT
WOULD BE THROUGH SUBSIDIZED.
HOUSING ASSISTANCE. IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT IS COMPLETELY
OUT OF THE QUESTION OR IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE WORKED
ON. I DON'T THINK ANYTHING IS
OUT OF THAT'S THE GREAT PART
ABOUT C. S. B. G. AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT TIME. DR RANDALL
AS WELL IS EVERY TIME TWO YEARS
EVERY COMMUNITY RIGHTS WHAT
IT'S CALLED THE COMMUNITY
ACTION PLAN IT GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT A LOT MORE TEETH IF
YOU GO TO THOSE PUBLIC MEETINGS
OR EVEN IN WRITING MAKE
STATEMENTS THAT HAVE TO BE
INCLUDED IN THAT PLAN. THAT
SAYS WHAT YOUR IDEAS ARE OR
WHAT YOU THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT BECAUSE
MANY TIMES THOSE AREN'T
PARTICIPATED IN HIGHLY OR MAYBE
PEOPLE COME AND THERE'S ONE OR
TWO AGENDAS INSTEAD OF MAYBE A
BROADER AGENDA OF PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T REPRESENTED SO. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE STRONGLY ANY IDEAS
THAT ANY OF YOU HAD OR ANY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT I THINK
COLLUDED IN THAT COMMUNITY
ACTION PLAN BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
YOU GET CHANGE MADE IN THAT
COMMUNITY IS WHEN THE COMMUNITY
STATE THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED.
AND TWO MORE QUESTIONS IF I
MAY. ONE IS A FUNDS FOR DAKAR
RENEWAL I BELIEVE IS IN ONE OF
YOUR PRESENTATION YES SO THESE
FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR DOCKERY
YES. HUH ALL RIGHT IT DID IT
AGAIN THE REQUIREMENT IS THE
TO. THE TO QUALIFY FOR CIVIL
CRACKED OKAY. MY LAST QUESTION.
HAS TO DO WITH FEDERAL
INVESTIGATIONS. SECTION SIX
SEVEN SIX BE SEVEN TALKS ABOUT
THIS PROVIDE AN ASSURANCE THAT
THE STATE WILL PERMIT AND
COOPERATE WITH FEDERAL
INVESTIGATIONS UNDERTAKEN IN
ACCORDANCE WITH SECTION SIX
SEVEN EIGHT D. DOES THIS
INCLUDE IMMIGRATION STATUS SO
IF THE FEDS ARE ASKING FOR
PROGRESSION STATUS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
PROVIDED IF THAT IS SOMETHING.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
HASN'T COME UP IN THE PAST AND
I UNDERSTAND WHY YOU A YOU POSE
THE QUESTION AND THAT'S
SOMETHING I WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
BACK IN AND FOR THE RESEARCH TO
GIVE YOU A CORRECT ANSWER.
THANK YOU I CAN TELL YOU THAT
EACH LOCAL COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCY HAS A LOCAL PLAN TO
RESPOND. WE ONLY RESPOND IF
THERE'S AB WARRANT. WE WILL NOT
GIVE JUST BLANKET INFORMATION
SO I THINK EVERY AGENCY. KIND
IT DOES WHAT THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH OBVIOUSLY ONCE
THAT OUR ARMS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. MIGHT RESPOND
DIFFERENT THAN PRIVATE NON
PROFITS ARE WILLING TO RESPOND.
BUT WE HAVE A VERY YOU KNOW AT
OUR OUR STAFF IS TRAINED OUR
SITE TO TRAINED. WE YOU KNOW
HAVE SAMPLES OF CORRECT WARRANT
SITTING CORRECT WARRANTS WE
HAVE. SECURE AREAS SO WE HAVE
SIMPLEX ABILITY BECAUSE WORD
NONPROFIT BUT I WOULD SAY THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE ARMS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROBABLY HAVE A
DIFFERENT. RESPONSE. TO THEM
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO I HAVE A JUST
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ARE.
MISTER LEE I JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF GET A SENSE FROM YOU
WHAT TRENDS OR CHANGES YOU KNOW
HAVE YOU OBSERVED AND THE
PROGRAM OVER THE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS. OR DURING YOUR
TIME. OKAY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND SO I HAD MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT. THAT IN TERMS OF THE
CHANGES ONE IS GOING BEYOND
REPORTING AS WE ARE LOOKING TO
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM'S ABILITY
TO. QUANTIFY IT'S TRUE IMPACT
ON THE CLIENTS THAT WE SERVE AS
WELL AS- POVERTY IN THE STATE
THE SECOND WILL BE THE AND THIS
EMERGING ISSUE OF HOUSING. AND
THE HOMELESS. POPULATION THAT
THAT THE STATE IS MOBILIZING TO
BETTER ADDRESS AND THEN I WOULD
SAY ARE. IN ADDITION TO THAT
FOR FROM A DEPARTMENT
STANDPOINT DISASTER RESPONSE IS
ANOTHER AREA YOU KNOW MIGHT
PROBABLY GOING BACK OVER THE
PAST FOUR FIVE YEARS IT WAS THE
DROUGHT YOU KNOW EMERGENCY THAT
WE WERE RESPONDING TO NOW THAT
HAS EVOLVED INTO WILDFIRES THAT
THAT WE ARE DEALING WITH THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACTING. A GREAT
DEAL OF OUR CAL COMMUNITIES AS
WELL AS CONTRIBUTING TO THE
HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH AS A STATE SO
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WAYS THAT
ARE AGENCIES IN THE DEPARTMENT
CAN BETTER AND BETTER
INTERSECT. AND RESPOND. TO THIS
DEFINITELY IS THE IT HAS THE
IMPACT ON THOSE THAT WE SERVE.
SO I KNOW YOU MENTIONED AND
TOUCHED ON AND NATURAL
DISASTERS. WHAT WHAT ROLE HAS
THE DEPARTMENT OR THE PROGRAM
PLAYED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MOST RECENT NATURAL DISASTERS
AND WE HAD HERE IN THE STATE.
GREAT CUSTOMER REQUEST IN. SO
THE PARKING PLACE TO ROLL SO
DEPARTMENTS CONNECTED TO THE
STATE RESPONSE SO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCIES AND CAL
REMEMBERS YOU SEE SERVICE
RESPONSE WE ARE PART OF THAT
NETWORK OF STATE DEPARTMENTS
THAT RESPOND AND WE USE THE
INFORMATION THAT WE OBTAIN FROM
THERE TO. TO RELAY TO OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO BE AS RESPONSIVE
AS POSSIBLE TO THE NEEDS THAT
EXIST. DURING AND FOLLOWING A
NATURAL DISASTER IN ADDITION.
WE ARE SERVICE NETWORKS INCLUDE
ENERGY PROVIDERS AS WELL AS OUR
C. S. B. T. FUNDED AGENCIES.
AND THOSE THAT THE MINISTER THE
ENERGY PROGRAMS HAVE OTHER
EMERGENCY PROVISIONS THEY'RE
BUILT INTO THE PROGRAM. THAT
CAN BE MADE AVAILABLE UPON THE
NATURAL DISASTER SO FOR EXAMPLE
A TRANSPORTATION SERVICES HOME
VOUCHERS ASSISTANCE WITH ENERGY
OR PROVIDING TEMPORARY
GENERATORS AND THINGS THAT
NATURE THOSE ARE THE PROVISIONS
THAT CAN BE PROVIDED UNDER THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM SO. IT'S
CRITICAL AND TRY TO ORCHESTRATE
HOW THOSE RESOURCES CAN BE
BROUGHT TO BEAR ON THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S BEEN IMPACTED
BY NATURAL DISASTER IN IN OUR
IN OUR AND THEN ON THE
COMMUNITY THE CSPC SIDE. AGAIN
GOING BACK TO THE FACT THAT
THESE DOLLARS A MORE FLEXIBLE
IN THOSE ORGANIZATIONS OR
SOMETIMES POSITION TO DO
SOMETHING MORE THAN JUST THOSE
THAT ARE OFF THE OFFERINGS OF
AND YOU PROGRAM. IS WORKING
WITH THOSE ORGANIZATIONS TO
FIGURE OUT. WHAT HOW THEY CAN
POSITION THEMSELVES TO DO AN
IMMEDIATE ASSESSMENT AND THEN
ALSO IDENTIFY WHAT AND NEEDS
THAT THEY FEEL THAT THEY CAN
IMPACT YOU KNOW. WITH THE FUNDS
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO IN
ADDITION WE'VE ALSO STREAMLINED
HOW ARE PROGRAMS CAN RESPOND TO
A NATURAL DISASTER SO MAKING
SURE THAT WE CAN TRIGGER OUT
HOW WE CAN MAKE AVAILABLE
THESE DOLLARS THAT THAT WE HAVE
IN THE DISCRETIONARY FIND MAKE.
THOSE LAWS AVAILABLE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE AGENCIES. THANK YOU.
I KNOW YOU ALSO TOUCHED A
LITTLE BIT ON ON THE DROUGHT
CAN YOU TELL ME A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT IN THE WORK
THAT YOU HAVE. THAT AS A
DEPARTMENT YOU'VE DONE UNDER
THIS PROGRAM. WITH THE DROUGHT
RESPONSE THERE WERE TWO THINGS
BOTH WITH THE DISCRETIONARY
DOLLARS. WE FIND THE WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SO BASICALLY
IT WAS. MODELED AFTER OUR
FRONTAL ENERGY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES UTILITY
ASSISTANCE TO HELP INDIVIDUALS
PAY THEIR- COVER THE COST FOR
THE HOME ENERGY WE PROVIDED
SIMILAR SYSTEMS FOR WATER THEY
WORRY INDIVIDUALS DURING THE
DRY OTHER INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD
THE- IMPLEMENTS THAT WERE
IMPACTED OR LOST THEIR JOBS
DURING THE DROUGHT. AND WE'RE
HAVING DIFFICULTY MAKING ENDS
MEET AND ALSO THERE WERE COST
INCREASE COSTS TO WATER SERVICE
AND ACCESS THAT WE WERE TRYING
TO HELP OUR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
BETTER COPE WITH. IN ADDITION
WE DID RECEIVE A SMALL
ALLOCATION ARE SMALL
APPROPRIATIONS GENERAL FINDS
THAT WAS USED TO ESTABLISH TO
DROUGHT EMERGENCY. ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM DATA PROVIDED EIGHT A
VARIETY OF SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
TO INDIVIDUALS THAT WORKED IN
THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY THAT
HAD THEIR EMPLOYMENT IMPACTED
DIRECTLY BY THE DROUGHT SO THAT
PROVIDED HOUSING ASSISTANCE
VOUCHERS EMPLOYMENT TRUCK JOB
TRAINING. ALSO RETRAINING IN
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY SO FOLKS ARE
WORKING AGRICULTURE THEY COULD
WORK IN TRUCK DRIVING OR
SOMETHING ELSE SO IT WAS A
VARIETY OF SUPPORTS TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS WHETHER THE STORM A
AND B. AND GET ON THEIR FEET
FINANCIALLY. AND OVERCOME SOME
OF THE IMPACTS OF THE DROUGHT.
OKAY I'D I'D JUST DONE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR RESPONSE
AYE AYE EARLIER TODAY I HEARD
FROM A MEMBER OF MY COMMUNITY
THAT. DOESN'T HAVE HAS A SPOTTY.
ENERGY AND AT YOU SAID HIS IN
THERE YOU KNOW IN THEIR HOME
AND UP AND ALSO WATER IS STILL
A MAJOR ISSUE EVEN EVEN THE ONE
LONGER DROUGHT SO I YEAR THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT TRULY NEAR
AND DEAR. AND SPECIFIC TO MY TO
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
AS I'M SURE THERE ARE OTHER
PARTS OF BROWN'S MONEY AS WELL.
SO BIG SO MUCH FREE RESPONSE I
DO HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION. MORE
SO FOR OUR. OUR COMMUNITY
ACTION I WANTED TO REALLY. GET
AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW IT IS
THAT YOU RECRUIT OF YOU KNOW
FOR YOUR BOARD MEMBERS. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU HAVE TO.
HAVE HAVE IT BE REFLECTIVE OF
THE OF THE COMMUNITY THAT IT
SERVES SO AND EVERYBODY IF YOU
HAVE TO GET TO THE SAME END
POINT BUT HOW YOU GET THERE'S
DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON YOUR
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCY ARE I
CAN TELL YOU THAT MOST OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AGENCIES ARE
VERY SIMILAR. I'M IN HOW THEY
RECRUIT AND IT HAS TO BE A
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS FOR THE LOW
INCOME REPRESENTATION IN OUR
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY WE
ADVERTISE OPENINGS THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS YEAH AND- HELP
PEOPLE GET LOW INCOME PEOPLE TO
SIGN A PETITION FOR THEM TO
RYAN AND THEN WE DO A BALLOT
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY CENTERS.
THERE'S COMMUNITIES THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE COMPETITION AND
THERE'S COMMUNITIES FOR YOU
DON'T HAVE COMPETITION AND SO
WHEN ONLY ONE PERSON SIGNS UP
WE JUST TO A PUBLIC NOTICE AND
THEN THAT PERSON IS SEATED A
THIRD OF OUR BOARD OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS. SO MANY TIMES WE TRY
TO GET THEM FROM EACH FIVE OF
EACH OF OUR FIGHT SUPERMAN'S
ARIAL DISTRICTS AND SO WE SEND
A BLANKET LETTER TO ALL OF THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND THOS
SUPERVISOR DISTRICTS WHEN WE
HAVE AN OPENING AND SAY THIS IS
KIND OF OUR MISSION THIS IS
WHAT THE OBLIGATION WOULD BE.
AND THEN IF AND YOU HAVE A
TRYST AND THEN WE LET THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS DECIDE
AMONGST THEMSELVESBECAUSE
THAT'S NOT YOU KNOW AUTHOR HELP
STRING THAT WE WANT TO PUT ARE
TELLING AND THE THIRD WAY THAT
WE HAVE WITH MAJOR
ORGANIZATIONS AND OUR
DEFINITION OF A MAJOR
ORGANIZATION IS SOMETHING
SOMEBODY THAT HAS A MINIMUM OF
TWENTY FIVE MEMBERS. CAM THAT
REPRESENT TEN SHARES OUR VISION
AND MISSION I'M IN THE
COMMUNITY I'M NOT AN
APPLICATION PROCESS AND THE
BOARD THEMSELVES DECIDES FROM
THE APPLICATION PROCESS WHAT
COMMUNITY GROUP WOULD WOULD
CERTAIN THE MOST DIVERSE.
POPULATION OR MAYBE AREAS THAT
WERE NOT BEING HEARD. SO IT'S A
VERY DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR TIME HERE DAY FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE REALLY APPRECIATE
IT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS AT THIS. IF SOMEONE.
SO NEXT TIME BUT LIKE TO COLOR
SECOND PANEL
. AND IF YOU CAN
JUST PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION AND- PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU.
ALREADY. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS PATRICIA NICHOLS BUTLER AND
I'M THE CEO COMMITTEE ACTION
PARTNERSHIP CONSENT MEDINA
COUNTY. I THINK YOU CENTER
AUTONOMOUS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GOING THIS WAY AS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY REGARDING THE IMPORTANCE
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK
GRANT. FUNDING IN OUR COUNTY.
IT MAKES A HUGE IMPACT BUT THE
RESIDENTS THAT WE SERVE EACH
AND EVERY DAY. I JOIN YOU TODAY
TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME EXAMPLES
OF OUR COUNTY AND THE
INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING POVERTY. LET ME TELL
YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE. AND
HOW WE'RE ABLE TO LEVERAGE THAT
FUNDING IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN RECEIVED A GRANT OF A
PROXY TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF CAN YOU SERVICES
BLOCK GRANT FUNDING. AND WE
WERE ABLE TO LEVERAGE THAT
FUNDING TO A TOTAL BUDGET OVER
TWENTY FOR ALMOST TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
SHOWS YOU THE ABILITY. AND THE
BENEFIT OF A COMMUNITY SERVICES
BLOCK GRANT IN ALLOWING US TO
NOT ONLY PROVIDE WHAT WE CALL
THE ADMINISTRATIVE. OR AGENCY.
BUT ALSO. TO BE ABLE TO ATTRACT
NOT ONLY OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
FUNDS. BUT ALSO PRIVATE FUNDS
THAT WE APPLY FOR ON A REGULAR
BASIS. SO WITHOUT FINDING WE
LEVERAGE ABOUT NINE DOLLARS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR CCG FUNDING. IT IS
CRITICAL FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE LIFE THE SAME SERVICES
THE SAME RATING ACCOUNTING TO
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS. THE
LARGEST COUNTY. NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IN THE UNITED
STATES. BY POPULATION WERE JUST
OVER TWO MILLION. AND FROM AS A
SLICE WE ARE NOT ONLY LARGE BUT
WE ARE. AND WE HAVE A PARTS WE
TWENTY ONE SQUARE MILES OF LAND
MASS. MAKING IT THE FIFTH MOST
POPULOUS COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA.
16% OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY WHICH IS
LARGER THAN THE AVERAGE FOR THE
STATE. ALREADY RATE IS EVEN
WORSE FOR BOTTOM ALL
POPULATIONS SUCH AS SINGLE
WOMEN CHILDREN AND ETHNIC
MINORITIES. ADDITIONALLY
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES. FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
ADULTS AND CHILDREN SEVENTEEN
ACCOUNT LIVE IN FOOD INSECURE
HOUSEHOLDS. I LIKE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE USE THE SBG FUNDING FOR AND
HOW THEY HELP MEMBERS OF THESE
VITAL POPULATIONS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WE ACTUALLY
PARTNERSHIP SEVENTY NOW
OPERATES THE LARGEST FOOD BANK
IN THE COUNTY. WE CONTRACT WITH
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED LOCAL
AGENCIES WHICH INCLUDE CURTIS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY CENTERS TO OPERATE
FOOD PANTRIES. WITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS WE DISTRIBUTED
OVER FIFTEEN NINE MILLION
POUNDS OF FOOD. LAST YEAR WE
PROVIDED OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND AND DUPLICATED
HOUSEHOLDS WITH FREE FOOD
THROUGH THESE PANTRIES
ADDITIONALLY WE CONTRACT WITH
TWENTY FIVE SOUP KITCHENS
ACROSS THE COUNTY THAT PROVIDED
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND NINE
THOUSAND NUTRITIOUS MEALS TO
THE MALL FOOD IN CONCERT IN
SECURE INDIVIDUALS. IN OUR
COUNTY. OUR FOOD BANKS STARTED
THREE NEW EXCITING PROGRAMS
WITHIN THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS
THE FIRST IS OUR SENIOR CHOICE
PROGRAM. WE WERE EXCITED ABOUT
THAT PROGRAM BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE SENIORS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
POVERTY AND SO THIS PROGRAM
ALLOWED US TO PARTNER WITH
SIXTEEN. A CENTERS THROUGHOUT
SAN MARINO COUNTY AN APARTMENT
LOCATIONS PROVIDE HEALTHY FOOD
TO THOSE SENIORS RESIDING THE
SEVEN A FARMER'S MARKET
SETTING. AND WITHOUT SETTING I
INDIVIDUALS BECOMING A SELECT
ORGANIC PRODUCE ANY TYPE OF
FOOD THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE
MOST OFTEN IT'S HEALTHY FOOD
FOR THE SENIORS. IN ADDITION WE
PROVIDE SENIORS WITH HYGIENE
ITEMS THAT WE PROCURE IN TERMS
OF DONATIONS AND FOR THE
SENIORS LIVING ON A FIXED
INCOME THE AVAILABILITY OF
FRESH PRODUCE AND OTHER HEALTHY
FOOD ITEMS. HAS BEEN LIFE
CHANGING. ANOTHER NEW PROGRAM
WE STARTED AS A RESULT OF IS
CONDUCTING A POVERTY SYMPOSIUM.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AND
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AT OUR
LOCAL UNIVERSITIES. WE
IDENTIFIED THAT A LOT OF THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE ATTENDING
COLLEGE DID NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
FOOD. AND THAT WITH THIS AGAIN
THE BEAUTY OF CSP G. AT THE END
THAT ALLOWED US TO IDENTIFY IN
THE- AND TO COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION TO THAT NEED. SO WE
DEVELOPED WHAT'S CALLED THE
CAMPUS COVER PROGRAM. WHICH
CAUSES THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
EIGHT LOCAL COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES PROVIDE THEIR TO
FOOD AND SECURE STUDENTS.
HYGIENE ITEMS AND OTHER
SUPPLIES. AND THE THIRD PROGRAM
THAT WE DEVELOPED WAS OUR FOOD
PHARMACY PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
IS A PARTNERSHIP WITH A PRIVATE
SECTOR COMPANY CALL LANDMARK
HEALTH. THE FOCUS OF THIS
PROGRAM IS UNIQUE THAT IN THAT
IS HELPING LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
DIABETES BUT DISSIPATE IN THE
PROGRAMMING GO THROUGH A SIX
WEEK DIABETES EDUCATION COURSE
INCLUDING HEALTHY COOKING
DEMONSTRATIONS. OF PARTICIPANTS
WHEN THEY BEGIN THE PROGRAM
THEIR BLOOD IS DRAWN AND
CHECKED ON THE FIRST SESSION
AND READ JOHN AT VARIOUS
INTERVALS OVER A SIX MONTH
TRACKING TO SELL THEIR PROGRESS
AND SUCCESS. THE FOODS PHARMACY
PROGRAM HAS NOT ONLY TOPIC
DISMISS THE IMPORTANCE OF
HEALTHY EATING HABITS. IT HAS
PROVIDED THEM WITH MAGICAL
IMPROVEMENTS IN THEIR HEALTH
AND WE KNOW FROM OUR STUDIES
THAT WE'VE DONE THAT LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS. DISPROPORTIONATELY
ARE AFFECTED IN TERMS OF THEIR
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND SO WHAT BY
US BEING ABLE TO TEACH THEM
THROUGH. CLASS COOKING
DEMONSTRATIONS AND ALSO
PROVIDING THE FOOD. FOR THOSE
DEMONSTRATIONS MANY OF THEM
REPORTED IMPROVED RESULTS. WE
STARTED ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY INDIVIDUALS LAST YEAR
AND ABOUT 59% OF THOSE SO THE
CHANGE IN THERE AB ONE C.
LEVELS. IN ADDITION TO THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND THAT WE
OPERATE THROUGH OUR FOOD BANK
WE ALSO UTILIZE THE SBT FUNDING
TO SUPPORT OUR FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM CONSISTS OF CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES IN WHICH
CLIENTS ARE GUIDED TO MEET
SPECIFIC GOALS SUCH AS GETTING
AN EDUCATION. OPENING THE
BUSINESS OR GETTING A JOB. WE
OPERATE A TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM WHICH HAS EIGHT UNITS.
IN WHICH INDIVIDUALS RESIDE FOR
UP TO TWELVE MONTHS. AND AT THE
END OF THAT TWELVE MONTHS. THEY
ARE ABLE TO MOVE ON TO
PERMANENT HOUSING IF THEY'RE
NOT THERE EXTENDED UP FOR
ANOTHER TWELVE MONTHS UNTIL
WE'RE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'VE TRANSITION OFF OF.
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AND THAT THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAIN
WHATEVER PERMANENT HOUSING THE
IDENTIFY. THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
IN A VERY IMPORTANT SERVICE IN
OUR COUNTY BECAUSE WE KNOW
HOUSING COSTS ARE EXTREMELY
HIGH. NOT ONLY MOST OF OUR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES HAVE HAD IN THE
VIXEN. AND SOMETIMES TO WHICH
PRECLUDES THEM OR MAKES
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO GET A
LANDLORDS EXCEPT THE MEN TO
HOUSING. WE ALSO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO THOSE IN
NEED OF EMERGENCY HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION ASSISTANCE. AND
FINALLY OUR VALUE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM PROVIDES FREE TAX
PREPARATION TO MIDDLE AND LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COUNTY. AND I WANT TO THANK OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOMEZ REYES FOR
BEING SO SUPPORTIVE OF. OUR BY
THE PROGRAM AND COMING OUT IT
ACTUALLY HELPING US TO PROMOTE
THE PROGRAM THROUGHOUT SAN
MEDINA COUNTY BY DOING A PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT. THIS IS
THE JEEP GRAND IS A CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION PARTNERSHIPS
AMEGHINO COUNTY TO RELY THESE
CRITICAL IN LIFE CHANGING
PROGRAMS TO THE LOW INCOME
CITIZENS OF SAN MARINO COUNTY.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION TO YOU
THAT WITH OTHER FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WE RCEIVE WE'RE THE
LARGEST PROVIDER OF UTILITY
ASSISTANCE SO WE HELP KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON FOR MANY OF OUR
RESIDENTS. BECAUSE OF THE LIKE
HE PROGRAM. WHILE WE CANNOT I
WOULD THIS PROGRAM WITH OUR CSP
GEE IT IS DEFINITELY PROGRAM
THAT WE OPERATE IN PARTNERSHIP
AND PROVIDE THE- ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT FOR THAT PROGRAM. SO I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE HOW
IMPORTANT THESE FUNDS ARE FOR
ORGANIZATION. AND WHAT A
DIFFERENCE IT MAKES A
SEPARATING A COUNTY A COUNTY
THAT IS VERY MUCH STILL
STRUGGLING. THANK YOU. DOOR
MICROPHONE. I U. K. MY NAME IS
GREG GEAR I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA INDIAN DEVELOPMENT
COUNCIL OR AND SEE IDC USUALLY
ARE MOST PEOPLE RFER TO US AS
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE ON THE
USE OF COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAMS TO HELP POVERTY
LEVEL AMERICAN INDIANS AND
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
ACHIEVE SELF SUFFICIENCY.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF IF NOT THE
ONLY STATE IN THE UNION. THAT
HAS AN AMERICAN INDIAN SET
ASIDE UNDER THE COMMUNITY
SERVICE BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM.
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
CALIFORNIA HAS MAINTAINED AN
INDIAN SET ASIDE OF THREE POINT
9% OF THE CS BG ALLOCATION. THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA INDIAN
DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL IS ONE OF
TWO ELIGIBLE CSP G.
ORGANIZATIONS ALONG WITH THE
COULD DRIVE. THAT ARE BOTH THE
LIMITED PURPOSE AGENCY AND A
NATIVE AMERICAN INDIAN
ORGANIZATION OR AGENCY UNDER CS
THESE DESIGNATIONS. BOTH ENDS
THE IDC AND THE CUT A TRIBE
WERE ORIGINALLY DESIGNATED AS
LIMITED PURPOSE AGENCIES UNDER
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION. PRIOR TO THE
FORMATION OF THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT AND IT
WAS THAT STATUS THAT MADE AS AN
ELIGIBLE ENTITY THAT CONTINUES
TODAY. NC IDC IS A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT CORPORATION THE
MEMBERSHIP CONSISTING OF INDIAN
TRIBES AND INDIAN
ORGANIZATIONS. ARE ORIGINAL
DIRECT SERVICE AREA IS
NORTHWESTERN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
THE NAME NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
INDIAN DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL WE
STILL HAVE PRIMARY SERVICE
DIRECT SERVICES IN BOOTS ON THE
GROUND AND HUMBLE DON'T NOR
SISKIYOU AND TRINITY COUNTIES.
AND OFFICES IN EACH. BUT IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX WE WERE
APPROACH TO TAKE ON THE JOB OF
PASSING THROUGH AND
ADMINISTERING THE STATE WIDE.
COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE ELIGIBLE
ENTITY'S UNDER THE LAW. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FIFTY SEVEN
COUNTIES AND OVER ONE HUNDRED
TRIBES THAT WE WORK WITH
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN ANY GIVEN YEAR
AND LAST YEAR THERE WERE OVER
FOURTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE INDIAN
PEOPLE TOUCHED BY COMMUNITY
SERVICE BLOCK GRANT PROGRAMS IN
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES TO THIS LARGE AMERICAN
INDIAN ELIGIBLE BENEFICIARY
NETWORK THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND SEE IDC HAS ESTABLISHED A
SUBCONTRACTOR NETWORK OF
AMERICAN INDIAN ORGANIZATIONS
AND DELIVER DIRECT SERVICES.
THE MAJORITY OF THESE
SUBCONTRACTORS HAVE ALSO BEEN
DESIGNATED AS U DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR. NATIVE AMERICAN GRANTEES
UNDER THE WORKFORCE INNOVATION
AND OPPORTUNITY ACT OR W. Y. O.
A PROGRAM. OUR AMERICAN INDIAN
SET ASIDE PROGRAM. AUGMENTS
THESE EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
AND OTHER ANCILLARY SERVICES.
AND ALLOWS US TO CASE MANAGE
CLIENTS WITH BOTH CS BG AND W.
I. AWAY RESOURCES. TO PROVIDE
MORE FLEXIBILITY IN ADDRESSING
BARRIERS THE CONS FACE IN
ACHIEVING SUCCESS. IN MOST
INSTANCES THE ADDITION OF THIS
FUNDING HAS EXPANDED THE
CAPACITY. OF THE SUBCONTRACTOR
AGENCIES STRENGTHEN THEIR
MANAGEMENT AND OPERATIONAL
SYSTEMS. AND PROVIDED A
CATALYST TO DEVELOP ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES FOR THEIR
AMERICAN INDIAN SERVICE
POPULATIONS. WE'VE BEEN ASKED
ABOUT SOME OF THE INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS TODAY THAT WE HAVE
BEING DEVELOPED AND I'M PART
PROUD TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF
THEM. WE HAVE A ONLINE TRIBAL
COLLEGE CURRENTLY BEING
DEVELOPED BY CALIFORNIAN IN
MANPOWER CONSORTIUM WITHIN OUR
NETWORK TO DO ENTREPRENEURIAL
AND BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AND
BUSINESS START UP TRAINING
THEY'RE ALSO DOING CARE TAKER
TRAINING THEY'RE CURRENTLY IN
THE ACCREDITATION PROCESS. AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
EXCITING TO SEE ONLINE AND
DISTANCE LEARNING TO BE ABLE TO
REACH VERY RURAL INDIAN
RESERVATIONS AND COMMUNITIES
THAT OTHERWISE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. WE HAVE AN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PARTNER THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SCARE AMERICAN
INDIAN RESOURCE CENTER WAS
DEVELOPED ON SITE MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING THAT THEY HAVE
INTEGRATED INTO THEIR CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES. WORKING
WITH UST DOWN THERE AND THEIR
PROGRAM THEY DO PRACTICALS
INTERNSHIPS FOR THE GRADUATE
STUDENTS TO GET THEIR HOURS
UNDER SUPERVISION AND THEY'VE
INCORPORATED TRADITIONAL TRIBAL
MENTAL HEALTH. TRIBAL
TRADITIONAL HEALTH ASPECTS INTO
CONTEMPORARY COUNSELING
SERVICES AND TALK ABOUT
INTERGENERATIONAL TRAUMA AND
TALK ABOUT ISSUES THAT ARE VERY
UNIQUE AND SPECIFIC THE SOME OF
THE POPULATIONS THEY SERVE AND
THEY'RE ACHIEVING A GREAT
SUCCESS IN FACT WE'RE CURRENTLY
TALKING ABOUT. DISTANCE
MEDICINE AND WHETHER WE CAN
EXPAND THIS OUT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND IN OTHER ASPECTS
OF THE STATE. WE HAVE A HUGE IN
TERMS OF MARKETING AND OUTREACH
A HUGE EFFORT FOR CENSUS TWENTY
TWENTY THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT. OUTREACH
EFFORTS RIGHT NOW WITH IN
INDIAN COUNTRY IN STATE IS A
GENERAL ON THE ENTIRE STE MY
ENTIRE CS BG NETWORK IS
ACTIVELY ENGAGED WE HAVE SMALL
GRANTS FROM THE ON CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT. COMMITTEE THAT
ARE HELPING US FUND SOME OF OUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS EVERY TRIBE
EVERY SUBCONTRACTORS INVOLVED I
DIDN'T A FOR TRY BLOOM HENCE
THE LAST MONTH AND A HALF WITH
STAFF TABLING DOING OUTREACH
TRYING TO GET COMMUNITIES THAT
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO GET TO.
THE KLAMATH SALMON FESTIVAL OF
THE IRAQ TRIBES A SOVEREIGN
DAYS OF THE COOPER TRIED.
CULTURAL DAYS OF. THE WE ARE
DRIVING IN A WEEK OR TWO WILL
BE UP THE CALLER WAS MISTER.
BUT HOLLOW WITH ANY NATION
DOING THERE. WE'RE ONLINE WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA WE ARE DOING MAIL
CAMPAIGNS WERE DOING POSTER
CONTEST WITH KIDS. INDIAN
COUNTRIES ENGAGED AND WE'RE
GOING TO GET EVERY INDIAN
PERSON AND EVERY PERSON LIVING
IN INDIAN COUNTRY COUNTED THIS
YEAR. BROWN'S THE TABLE.
ANOTHER PROGRAM I'M EXCITED
ABOUT IS THE INDEED JUST
INDIGENOUS EDUCATIONAL ADVOCACY
PROGRAM BEING FUNDED BY A
FOUNDATION TO HELP INDIAN
PARENTS WITH DISABILITY
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES THEY
HAVE ARE YOU PEAS REVIVAL FOR
PLANS. THERE'S DISCIPLINE OR-
DIFFERENTIAL DISCIPLINE
HAPPENING IN THE SCHOOL WERE
ESTABLISHING AN EDUCATIONAL
ADVOCATE TO HELP EMPOWER
PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO BE ON
PARA COMMITTEES TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH THEIR CHILDREN TO GET
THEIR DISAPPEAR DISABILITY
PLANS RECOGNIZED BY THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND THIS IS PROGRAMS
STARTING UP IN NORTHWESTERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND. ANOTHER PROGRAM
THAT I'M VERY PROUD OF IS OUR
DISASTER RESPONSE ON AND SAID
YOU SEE IS ABLE TO UC SBG AND
SOME RAPID RESPONSE MONEY TO DO
INITIAL SURVEYING OF
COMMUNITIES AFTER A DISASTER.
AND WE THAT ARE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR AND GET THE NATIONAL
DISLOCATED WORKER GRANTS USED
TO BE CALLED NATIONAL EMERGENCY
GRANTS INTO PLAY TO DO CLEAN
UP. AND REPAIR ON RESERVATIONS
IN INDIAN COMMUNITIES. FROM
DAMAGES I CURRENTLY HAVE CREWS
WORKING ON THE FIRES OF THE
TWENTY SAID THE STORMS OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. MENDOCINO AND
NOW THE STORMS THAT HAPPEN AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR WE
ARE CALLING THE SEVERE STORMS
OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE ARE JUST
NOW BEEN TOLD THAT WE WILL BE
FUNDED FOR SOME CLEAN UP CREWS
FROM THAT ONE AS WELL. THESE
CREWS GO OUT AND HIRE
DISLOCATED OR LONG TERM
UNEMPLOYED INDIAN PEOPLE.
USUALLY FOR FIVE TO ACCRUE GIVE
THEM SOME TOOLS AND SOME
TRAINING AND PUT THEM IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY CLEAR GOLF
CULVERTS OR- CLEAR FIRE DAMAGED
FENCING OR BRUSH OR WORK ON
BUILDINGS OR WHATEVER IS
NECESSARY. TO TRYING CLEAN UP
AND REPAIR FROM VARIOUS
DISASTERS. IN REGARD TO THE ON
RESERVATION AND RANCHERIA
ALLOCATIONS IN C. IDC CONTRACT
DIRECTLY WITH EACH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT OR THEIR DESIGNATED
TRIBAL ENTITY FOR THE PROVISION
OF SERVICES WITHIN THE
RESERVATION RANCHERIA WE
SUCCESSFULLY USED THIS FUNDING
TO AUGMENT. EXISTING PROGRAMS
ON RESERVATIONS INITIATE NEW
SERVICES AND EXPAND CAPACITIES
TO ADMINISTER AND OPERATED
USUAL PROGRAMS. ON MANY SMALL
TRIBES GET UNDER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR ONE FIVE
ZERO ZERO ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED. I THINK THIRTEEN
TWENTY IS CURRENTLY THE MINIMUM
ALLOCATION. BUT THERE ARE A LOT
OF SMALL TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY THAT COMES
ALONG WITH IT OFTENTIMES GIVES
THEM THE ABILITY TO DO
SOMETHING VERY MEANINGFUL. SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU MIGHT
SEE ON TRIBES AS YOU LOOKED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS A
LOT OF COMMUNITY GARDENS. AND
OTHER RELATED WELLNESS AND
EXERCISE PROGRAMS YOU'RE SAYING
YOU THE EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT AND
USE CAREER EXPLORATION IN WORK
EXPERIENCE PROGRAMS. CULTURAL
AND LANGUAGE PROGRAMS. ADULT
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR ELDER EMERGENCY
SAFETY NET SERVICES AND SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES. WE APPRECIATE A
PARTNERSHIP THE AMERICAN INDIAN
SET ASIDE NETWORK IS
ESTABLISHED WITH NON NATIVE CSP
G. AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA SUCH
AS THE COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES YOU SEE SITTING HERE
AT THIS TABLE. AND THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE STAFF AND
LEADERSHIP OF THE COMPARTMENT
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT AS WE WORK ON
ADDRESSING POVERTY. AND
PROMOTING SELF SUFFICIENCY IN
INDIAN COUNTRY AS DESCRIBED IN
THE DRAFT PLAN BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I FINALLY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN MAINTAINING. THE
CALIFORNIA. SENATE SIDE FOR
INDIAN PEOPLE WITHIN THE CS BG
PROGRAM. IT IS UNIQUE. IT IS
EXTREMELY HELPFUL IT IS A LOT
OF A LOT OF SMALL TRIBES THAT
DON'T HAVE SOME OF THE
RESOURCES OF LARGER AND OTHER
TRIBES TO REALLY DO MEANINGFUL
ACTIVITIES. AND I THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO OUR STORY TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND STATE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME. TO SHARE ABOUT OUR
EXPERIENCE MY NAME IS THOMPSON
OR A ON THESE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE COMMUTER
ACTUALLY TO SEE IF YOU COUNTY
INC. AND JUST A LITTLE BIT I
I'VE BEEN THERE FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS I'VE BEEN IN THE FIELD A
BIT LONGER. AND FOLLOW PATRICIA
AS THE HEAD OF OUR STATE
ASSOCIATION PRECEDED BRENDA.
AND ALSO WAS CHAIR WHERE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION. OF THE
CAN ACTUALLY SEE IF YOU COUNTY
HAS SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
SERVE THE COUNTY OF NEW AND
OTHER SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
TO PROMOTE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
GREATER ECONOMIC SECURITY OF
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS. WE DO SO
THROUGH A BROAD VARIETY OF
STRATEGIES THAT RESPOND TO
NEEDS SO THIS IS JUST A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT US AS A AS A WHOLE
BEFORE FOCUSING ON WHAT I WAS
REQUESTED TO FOCUS IN ON. IN
THESE STRATEGIES WERE IN RANGE
FROM ENERGY EFFICIENCY TO FOOD
BANK TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
WORKERS HOMELESS FAMILIES AND
SENIORS. IN OUR WORK INVOLVES
MANY PARTNERS. AROUND SHARED
INTERESTS OF IMPROVING OUR
COMMUNITY IS FOR ALL OF US TO
LEVERAGE THE BENEFIT OF LIMITED
RESOURCES. WE'RE NONPROFIT
MEMBER OF THE STATE'S COMMUTERS
SERVICEABLE GRANT FUNDED
NETWORK. AND INCLUDED IN THAT
THEIR BREATH OF ACTIVITIES IS
ALSO A VITAL INTEREST IN IN
INCREASE SEEN OUR OR TAX
PREPARATION ASSISTANCE ACTIVITY
THAT WE DO VERY WELL UP IN THE
NORTH STATE. ALONG WITH COOPER
SPREADING THAT AS MY COLLEAGUE
IS IN THE US CENSUS COMPLETE
COUNT EFFORTS. BUT FOR RIGHT
NOW I WANT TO FOCUS IN ON ON
THE ROLE OF SEIZE BG IN
DISASTER OF RESPONSE. AND WELL
I CAN SPEAK OF THIS SOMEONE
DISPASSIONATELY THERE ARE STILL
MANY WHO CANNOT. A NORMAL DAY
OUR WORK IS CHALLENGING A 20%
OF OUR POPULATION IS UNDER THE
POVERTY GUIDELINES ARE VACANCY
RATE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING I
READ ABOUT 1% AND YET ON
NOVEMBER EIGHTH THE CAMPFIRE
TURNED IT INTO THE WANTING. OF
BEST PRACTICES CALL FOR
PREPARATION BY NONPROFIT SUCH
AS OURS FOR CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
COULD CHALLENGE OR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE BUSINESS. BUT IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT THERE WAS ANYTHING
THAT COULD HAVE PREPARED ANYONE
FOR WHAT HAPPENED AS THE FIRE
WARD AT TIMES AT THE RATE OF
ONE FOOTBALL FIELD PER SECOND.
DISPLACING OVER 500-005-2000
PEOPLE AND WIPING OUT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND HOMES. I WOULD BE CA
AS FORTUNATE AS WITH OTHERS IN
OUR NETWORK AND IN OUR
COMMUNITY WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
CARE AND ARE COMMITTED TO OUR
MISSION AND OUR PURPOSE. WE HAD
STAFF WERE BURNED OUT OF THEIR
HOMES COME TO WORK DAYS LATER.
SO THAT THEY COULD HELP OTHERS.
IT HELPED US TO BE ABLE TO BE
NIMBLE IN OUR RESPONSE. HELP US
TO DEVELOP RESPONSES THAT
INVOLVED WITH THE NEED. THE V.
EIGHT ENGINE I DON'T WANT TO
PAINT THE PICTURE THAT WE WERE
THE ONLY ONES BECAUSE I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES I HEARD
THE TERM THAT THERE IS NO BOOK
TO ADDRESS DISASTERS LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED. BUT WE WERE ONE OF
MANY WITHIN A FEW HOURS OF THE
START OF A FIRE THAT BURNED FOR
TWO WEEKS OUR REGIONAL FOOD
BANK HAD FOOD ON ITS WAY TO
SURVIVORS IN WITHIN THE SAME
AMOUNT OF TIME THE STATE
DEPARTMENT COMMUTERS AND
DEVELOPMENT GAVE US THE GREEN
LIGHT TO DIVERT ENERGY BLOCK
GRANT FUNDS TO EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SUPPORT FUND. BUT WE
COULD HELP PUT UP FOLKS IN
HOTELS MOTELS. JUST TO GIVE ME
A SENSE OF HOPE INSTABILITY
WHILE HEARING DURING. THE FIRST
FEW HOURS OF WHAT THEY WERE
GOING TO BE LIVING FOR THE
COMING MONTHS. THISIS SIMILAR
RESPONSIVENESS STAY CST STAFF
MADE AVAILABLE FUNDING FROM THE
DISCRETIONARY GRANT PROGRAM.
OUT OF WHICH WE WERE THEN ABLE
TO THAN HELP FOLKS TO LOCATE
INTO WHATEVER AVAILABLE
APARTMENT HOUSING THERE WERE.
IN AND UNFORTUNATELY. FOUR ZERO
FORTUNATELY TO EVEN RELOCATE
OUT OF THE AREA BECAUSE- THE
ALL OF THE HOUSING WITHIN A
SEVENTY FIVE MILE RADIUS WAS
WAS TAKEN UP WITH SURVIVORS WHO
HAD. PLAYED A FLEA OF THE
DISASTER. THE DRAFT TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN CSP STATE
PLAN HAS ABLY DESCRIBED A
PORTION OF OUR RESPONSE TO THE
IMMEDIATE NEED TO HELP PRESERVE
PEOPLE'S HOPE IN THEIR LIMITED
FUNDS. ARE LEVERAGING FOODS
FUNDS FROM STATE CST AND OTHER
STATE AGENCIES WERE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THE FOLLOWING. WE
ASSISTED FORTY THREE HOUSEHOLDS
WITH AMER LEGION ASSISTANCE ON
SITE AT HOTELS TO STABILIZE AND
MINIMIZE TRAUMA. IN THE IMPACT
TO LIMITED RESOURCES OF
SURVIVOR FAMILIES. WITH SYSTEM
THIRTY ONE HOUSEHOLDS WITH
RAPID RE HOUSING ASSISTANCE
THAT ENABLE THEM TO MOVE INTO
THEIR VERY LIMITED HOUSING
AVAILABLE IN THE REGION. WE
ASSISTED FOR HOUSEHOLDS WITH
HOMELESS PREVENTION ASSISTANCE
TO KEEP FAMILIES FROM JOINING
THE RANKS OF THE HOMELESS. AND
WE DISTRIBUTED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DISASTER FOOD BOXES
WITH A HUNDRED FORTY SIX
THOUSAND POUNDS. OF HEALTHY
FOOD TO FAMILIES OF LINING UP
IN OUR STREET DISTRIBUTIONS.
YOU PROBABLY ALREADY SEEN ALL
THE VIDEOS ALL THE PHOTOS NONE
OF IT DOES DOES IT JUSTICE IF
YOU'RE EVER AT ALL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY ANY VISITORS WE
HAVE WE SAY GO VISIT PARADISE.
IT'S LIKE NOTHING ELSE YOU'VE
EVER SEEN. WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO IN THE RECOVERY PROCESS
AND WE'RE NOT THE ONLY
COMMUNITY THAT HAS SUFFERED A
DISASTER WE REALIZE THAT. BUT
YOU JUST NEED TO KNOW THAT.
NIMBLE AND AT THE NIMBLE AND
RESPONSIVE NETWORK EXISTS TO
LEVERAGE PARTNERSHIPS BOTH
ABOVE AND BELOW FOR SUCH TIMES
AS THIS AS AS A DISASTER AND WE
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THIS IS SPEECH YOU
PROGRAM. YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITE. AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE INFORMATION OF THE
ORGANIZATION THAT ARE PRESENT
MY NAME IS ROBERT AUGUST AROUND
THE CBO PRODUCE INCORPORATED
CENTRAL VALLEY. OUT WE WERE
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN AND WE'RE NONPROFIT BASED
IN CENTRAL VALLEY WE OPERATE IN
THE IN THE COUNTIES FRESNO
TULARE TEENS AND CURRENT. I'VE
HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING
LOWER PRICES NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SO IT REYES BE AGES WE
PRETTY WELL HAS SEEN THE
CHANGING OF ALL MANY TIMES OVER
THE ONE CONSTANT HAS BEEN A
CARE ANY OF OUR PURPOSE IN
HELPING CHANGE THE LIVES OF
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
IN ACHIEVING SELF SUFFICIENCY.
WHAT I ONLY BRING TO THE TABLE
MORE THAN BEING WITH OUR
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE A LOT OF
PASSION FOR FARMWORKERS A LOT
OF US COME FROM THE BACKGROUND
FAR WORKING COMMUNITIES SO OF
YOUR CEO IS A FORMER FARM
WORKER A LOT OF OUR STAFF ARE
AS WELL THAT'S WHAT KEEPS THE
GLUE TOGETHER ONE THING ELSE OF
THE PASSION FOR OUR STAFF HAVE
FOR ANYBODY COMES IN OUR DOORS
STREAM FARMWORKERS. OUR MISSION
IS TO PROVIDE EDUCATION JOB
TRAINING JOB PLACEMENT AND
OTHER SPORTS SERVICE THE FARMER
COULD FAMILIES IN MEDICAID
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS WE SERVICE
ANYBODY THAT COMES THROUGH OUR
DOORS BASICALLY CSP GPS IS THE
LEVERAGE TO BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
AND OFFER SERVICES AND THE WAY
I PUT IT IS WOULD LIKE TO ONE
STOP CENTER FOR FARMWORKERS.
THAT COME THROUGH OUR DOORS. WE
ALWAYS HAVE. RAISE THE MISSION
OF OUR OF OUR STAFF TO MAKE
SURE THAT SOMEBODY COMES UP
WITH SOMETHING. SERVICES
SOMETHING. OUR COMMUNITY. FIFTY
G. BLACK PLANK IS A VERY MUCH
NEEDED SERVICES TO SOCIAL
ECONOMIC DISADVANTAGE CUSTOMERS
A CENTRAL VALLEY. THE PROVIDES
YOU'LL SERVICES TO OUR OUR OUR
PRESIDENTS AND CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT INCLUDE JOB SEARCH
ASSISTANCE TRAINING SERVICES
RENTAL UTILITY CLOTHING MEDICAL
AND TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
ARRAY OF SERVICES SO WHAT ONCE
WORKERS TO MANY MANY FOR ONE
WORRIES ARE ANOTHER. ALSO WE'VE
BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER FARMWORKER FAMILIES A LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE LOOK UP
AT THE LOOK AT THE SCENE AND
CST. WILL OFFER A FULL RANGE OF
ENERGY SERVICES SUCH AS
APPLIANCES I ENERGY EFFICIENT
APPLIANCES WEATHER STATION AND
SOLAR WE ARE PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT WE CAN IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR OUR CUSTOMERS AND
HIGHER WITHIN IT IS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT'S OUR MAIN
GOAL IS SELF SUFFICIENCY FOR
OUR CUSTOMERS. A LIVE IN THE
YEARS TO BE IMPACTED BY
DISASTER DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES IS TO GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET AHEAD HELP
UP BY BRINGING EDUCATION
SERVICES OR JOB BASICALLY. I
WILL BE ABLE TO HOPEFULLY OUR
CONTRACT TO SURVIVE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY HOMES FORTY THIS HOMES
WILL BE SOLAR AND. INSTALLATION
OF THOSE HOMES THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. JUST A COUPLE
OF STORIES THAT I HAVE A FOR
EXAMPLE OF OUR CUSTOMER DIEGO
PROGRESS FOR EXAMPLE IN.
FAIRBURY AT TWENTY NINETEEN
THEIR GROUP BUT AS CAME TO OUR
SANGER PRESS OFFICE IN SEARCH
OF WORK FORCE AND SUPPORT
SERVICES. AT THE TIME A ROMAN
HE WAS MARRIED SUPPORTING A
FAMILY FOR IT WAS A SEASONAL
FORMER EARNING MINIMUM WAGE. AB
PRODUCE HE WAS PROVIDED WITH C.
S. P. G. SPONSOR SERVICES. THE
ONE ROLE IN COMPLETED A PRESS
FOR A PROTEST TRIGGERING A
VOCATIONAL TRAINING CLASS THAT
WE OVERSEE. HE GOT HIS CLASS A
LICENSE. IN APRIL OF TWENTY
NINETEEN I'M A PROUD TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THERE WAS NOT A
FULL TIME TRY TO PRAY FOR. RAIN
SIXTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR IN THE
LONG HAS TO DEPEND ON THE WAY
TO SUPPORT HIS FAMILY A SIXTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR IS NOT A LOT
IN. A IT WAS. A IN A BIGGER
CITY BEEN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IT'S NOT BAD. DAVID VASQUEZ FOR
EXAMPLE IS ANOTHER OUR
CUSTOMERS. I CAME TO THE SELMA
PRODUCE OBVIOUSLY NEED A
WORKFORCE AND SUPPORT SERVICES.
AT THE TIME OF HIS REGISTRATION
WAS A SEASONAL FARM WORKERS
EARNING MINIMUM WAGE IS
PROBABLY TO FIND STABLE
EMPLOYMENT. WITH THE HELP OF US
IN PROTEUS HE RECEIVES HE'S BG
SPONSOR. SERVICES OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND JOB RATING SCALE.
IN ADDITION HE A ROLE THIS IS
ACTUALLY COMPLETED ALSO ANOTHER
TRUCK DRIVING TRAINING. HE IS
NOT FULL TIME TRUCK DRIVERS
EARNING FIFTEEN FIFTY PER HOUR
WITH FULL BENEFITS. THIS IS
JUST A SMALL SMALL SAMPLE OF
PEOPLE TO COME THROUGH OUR
DOORS. BECAUSE WE IN OUR
FANCIES BG IS GIVES A SEPARATE
DELIVERIES ALL OUR RESOURCE
COLLECTIVELY TOGETHER. ARE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS OUT COMPRISES SIX
DIVISIONS. WHICH INCLUDE WE ARE
THE NATIONAL GRANT T. ONE SIX
AM FROM WORKER PROGRAM IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OF ONE OF FIVE
FIVE OTHER SISTER AGENCIES
THROUGH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED A DIRECT THE BID FUNNY
DIRECT MIGRATION FARMWORKERS IN
OUR LOCATIONS WE ALSO THE LOCAL
BUT THE WORD TITLE TO FUNDING
FROM FROM FROM THE EAST SIDE OF
THE STATE. ALSO WE DO ADULT
EDUCATION ALSO WE ALSO RECEIVE
WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAMS EACH
OF OUR COUNTIES AND THEN WE
ALSO OFFER FOR A FORMER
TEMPORARY HOUSING. DISLOCATED
ELKRIDGE WORK AT THE LOCAL I.
EIGHTY D. AND ALSO ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS CS BG IS
UTILITY LAST SUPPLEMENT AND
PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICES IN THE
FORM OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ADULT EDUCATION. ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE WE PROVIDE
CITIZENSHIP CLASSES WITH RIVAL
CATION TRAINING SUCH AS OFFICE
AUTOMATION TRIED DRIVING IN
SOLAR INSTALLATION JUST. WITH A
FEW. REDUCE HIS STRESS
PREVENTION. THIS IS AYE SAFETY
YOU ALSO HAVE YOU SERVICES WE
ALSO HAVE A DEFERRED ACTION IF
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO THE
PROCESS IMMIGRATION SERVICES
THE NOT REACH. AND ALSO I WOULD
LIKE TO MENTION THAT ARE
IMMIGRANT COMMITTEE AT THIS
POINT SINCE LAST COUPLE YEARS
THE MESSAGING FROM THE NATIONAL
SITE IS BEEN REALLY EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING THAT MAY CREATE
SOME FEAR FOR OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY TO COME OUT AND JUST
TO GET SERVICES THAT BEING THAT
WE BRING TO THE TABLE I THINK
WITH OTHER PARTNERS IS THAT
WHERE TRUSTED ORGANIZATION THAT
THEY'RE WILLING TO TALK TO US
AND WE TRY TO CALM THOSE FEARS.
EVEN THOUGH SOMETIMES. A VERY
DIFFICULT GIVING YOU A
DISTRESSING TIMES. WE HAVE TO
MOBILE EMPLOYMENT CENTERS A
MOBILE UNITS TO TRAVEL TO A
COMMUNE SPUR BY SERVICES WE DO
OUR ENERGY ASSESSORS THAT WHEN
THEY GO OUT TO VISIT HOMES AND
DO WITH THE ASSESSMENT THE ALSO
INFORM THE RESIDENTS OF THE
HOMES OF THE OTHER SERVICES ARE
OFFERED AND YOU GET A CHANCE TO
SEE WHAT MAY BE NEEDED OR NOT
NEEDED. AND IN THE REFER TO US
AND WE- FOLLOW UP. AND YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES AS- YOU
KNOW WE HAD CLASSES IN AB III.
AND WITH A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
AND VISITORS. RECEIVE HER HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. ENDORSES IN CLASSES.
EIGHTY EIGHT THAT WENT THROUGH
OUR CLASSES AND TING GOT YOUR
CITIZENSHIP. ARE WE HAPPY SO
CLASSES WHEN WHICH NINETY ONE
PERSON PARTICIPANTS WHEN THEY
ATTEND CLASS WHAT WE DO ALSO IS
PROVIDING THE CHILD CARE SO
THEY CAN FOCUS ON THEIR
YOURSELF. AND A TOTAL OF. ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX SERVICES WERE GIVEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO FIVE MINUTES TO
MAKE YOU FAMILIES EIGHTY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ENROLLED IN
A TRAIN SERVICE ALSO RECEIVE A
SUPPORT SERVICES TO HELP DURING
THE TRAINING. AND YEAH OFF ALL
I CAN SAY AGAIN IS THAT. THE
WAY WE WE'VE ALWAYS KIND OF
APPROACH OUR SERVICES. AND
LEVERAGE WITH OUR PARTNERS A
LOCAL COMMITTEE ACTION AGENCIES
HAVE BEEN VERY EXTREMELY.
ORIENTED TO HELP EACH OTHER AS
MUCH AS WE CAN. WE ALSO ARE THE
ONE STOP OPERATOR IN THREE
COUNTIES. ONE IN DELANO. FOR
LOCAL WORKFORCE INVESTMENT AREA
ALSO IN IN AND FRESNO COUNTY.
ON THE- EAST SIDE OF FRESNO
COUNTY AND ALSO. IN SURRY
COUNTY WE ARE SO CONSIDERED ONE
STOP OPERATOR. SO THAT'S THE
LEVY SAID SEIZE BG BRINGS FOR
AN ORGANIZATION LIKE OURS. THAT
WE ALL RIGHT WE UNDERSTAND ALSO
TO THAT WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES. AND THE MEETING THAT
WE TRY TO DO THIS LEVERAGES
MUCH AS WE CAN. WE ARE HEAVILY
INVOLVED WITH THE COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEES AS WELL. FROM
THE INSIDE OUT WE WILL ASSIST
IN ANY WAY POSSIBLE THAT WE
CAN. WE PARTNER WITH THE
CONSULAR MEXICO HUSTLING
SERVICES. TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MESSAGING IS CORRECT AND ALSO.
TO INFORM OF THE SERVICE THAT
WE DO PROVIDE. AND IT CAN YOU
KNOW. OUT OF OUR LOCATIONS. WE
VIEW OURSELVES TO BE THE ONE
STOP OPERATOR FOR SERVICES WITH
MURDER SEASON FARMWORKERS AND
OTHER PEOPLE. AND THEY'RE
PRETTY MUCH AND YEAH I CAN
ONLY. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SURE THAT. C. S. B.
C. IS BG FOR US HAS BEEN REALLY
THE TOOL ON EMERGING. OPINION
THAT WE DEPRIVE FULL RANGE OF
SERVICES WITH US USE BG. IT WAS
VERY DIFFICULT. TO MOVE FORWARD
AND ABLE TO PURSUE MANY MORE
SERVICES. THANK YOU. HI HI MY
NAME IS FOR THE PROGRAM I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATION FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION PARTNERSHIP OF
KERN AND I'M THE PROXY FOR
JEREMY TO BIAS USER CO
UNFORTUNATELY HE'S TRAVELING
FOR THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE SO
HE'S NOT HERE SO YOU HAVE BEEN
AND I'M JOINED BY OUR BOARD
MEMBER PASTOR MELONES WHO'S IN
THE AUDIENCE NOW AND HE
REPRESENTS OUR PRIVATE SECTOR
WE ALSO OPERATE A TRIPARTITE
BOARD OF FIFTEEN MEMBERS. I'M
SO CAP QUE BASED OUT OF CURRENT
SECURE WOMAN ON HER TITLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE A REPRESENT
I REPRESENT PERSON THAT
REPRESENTS YOU ON OUR BOARD AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE JOSE
ONBOARD HE'S IS A GREAT
ADDITION I'M CAP K. IS A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT OR NOT A
PUBLIC CAPPER PRIVATE CAP ARE
ALLOCATION FIRST USE BG RIGHT
NOW WE GET ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION OF THAT IT SHARED AMONG
ABOUT SEVEN PROGRAMS ON AND
I'LL BE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE PROGRAMS ON TODAY. AND IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
PLEASE TRY MEN SO ONE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT HELP SUPPLEMENT
THE CCG PROGRAM HEALTH
SUPPLEMENTS AS OUR VITA PROGRAM
WHICH IS NOTED IN THE STATE
PLAN I BELIEVE ON PAGE THIRTY
FOUR AND SO OUR CAT K. VITA
PROGRAM IS A YEAR ROUND FREE
TAX PREPARATION ETERNALLY
SERVICES I PROGRAM FOR LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME INDIVIDUALS I'M
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TAX FILING SEASON AND
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH A LOCAL
UNITED WAY BECAUSE WE SHARE
THAT EFFORT. WE HAD TOTAL
REFUNDS ON THAT WERE ABOUT
ELEVEN MILLION IN FEDERAL AND
STATE EITC DOLLARS AROUND FIVE
MILLION ALTOGETHER THAT JOINT
EFFORTS TO ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
A LITTLE BIT MORE INSTANT
DOUSING UNIQUE USERS THE
NINETEEN TAX SEASON I'M WE ALSO
ARE IT STABLE ON CAT COMMUNITY
SERVICES EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
SEE SAID THAT'S ANOTHER CAP
AGENCY BASED OUT OF TULARE AND
THEY'VE BEEN ARE. AWESOME
PARTNER I'M WITH CAL EA T. SEAT
WHICH IS A PROGRAM AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY THAT
INCREASES AWARENESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE LOW INCOME.
ON AND FOR US IT'S BEEN. GREAT
BECAUSE SEIZE THAT HOUSE IS
REALLY NEAT MODEL I'M THAT IS
CALLED NEXT PROGRAM THAT
HIGHLIGHTS INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
PART OF THE WELFARE TO WORK
PROGRAM SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT TO SHARE TO SO
WE'RE LEARN I'M LEARNING A LOT
TODAY FROM OUR BROTHER AND
SISTER CAP AGENCIES. ABOUT SOME
OF THE COOL PROGRAMS THAT
THEY'RE RUNNING BUT SEES THAT
SHOULD BE DEFINITELY
HIGHLIGHTED FOR SOME OF THE
NEAT THINGS THAT THEY'RE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE ON KELLY ATC
DOLLARS. I'M I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE BLIGHTED JUST A LITTLE BIT
STEP FURTHER AND WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO DO FOR THE UPCOMING TAX
SEASON IS. ON INCORPORATE A%
FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT PIECE
WHERE WERE FILING TAXES WELL
FOLKS ARE ACTUALLY RECEIVING
THEIR TAXES BUT WHAT ARE THEY
DOING WITH IT. IT WHAT KIND OF
COMPREHENSIVE CARE WE PROVIDING
TO THEM IN TERMS OF BUDGETING
WHAT IS SHORT TERM LONG TERM
PLANS LOOK LIKE SO WE'D LIKE TO
INCORPORATE THAT. RIGHT NOW
WE'RE UTILIZING A MODEL CALLED
YOUR MONEY YOUR GOALS AND NOT
MODEL SEEMS TO BE WORKING IN
OUR EASTERN ON RESOURCE CENTER
AND MEET SMALLER IT'S A SMALLER
COMMUNITY. BUT FOLKS ARE ABLE
TO KIND OF ADDRESS SOME OF
THEIR BUDGETING ISSUES AND HOW
TO PLAN FOR THE FUTURE SO WE'D
LIKE TO INCORPORATE THAT IDEA
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CAPTURED
AUDIENCE. I'M THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORTED
PERSONALLY BY CSP G. IS OUR TWO
ONE PROGRAM TO CALL CENTER.
IT'S A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
INFORMATION REFERRAL SERVICES
PROGRAM. FOR THIS LAST CALENDAR
OF EIGHTEEN WE REACHED ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE ON
CALLS. WHICH WAS HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CALLS WHICH IS
HUGE FOR US WE ALSO SUPPLY BACK
OFFICE SERVICES FOR ABOUT FOUR
OTHER COUNTY SO NOT ONLY DO WE
DO CURRENT. WE ALSO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO. KINGS TO LATER.
POST MERCED WHICH ARE THE
MOUNTAIN VALLEYS AND
STANISLAUS. AND WE MAINTAIN A
DATABASE OF ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND COMMUNITY RESOURCES
FOR THE COUNTY OF KERN WHICH IS
REALLY GREAT BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
US TO PARTNER WITH SOME OF OUR
AGENCIES NOT ONLY BY PROVIDING
SERVICES. BUT ALSO LEVERAGING
SOME FINE SO WE CAN GET SOME
GRANTS. TOWARDS TWO ONE ONE ONE
OF THOSE PROGRAMS IS AB
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEM SO
OCTOBER OF EIGHTEEN IS WHEN CAP
CASE STARTED AND BECAME THE
DESIGNATED COORDINATED ENTRY
SYSTEM FOR CURRENT SO WHAT THAT
BASICALLY MEANS IS THAT. ALL
HOMELESS CALLS THAT ARE COMING
INTO THE COUNTY COMING THROUGH
TWO ONE ONE THEY'RE IDENTIFIED
AS A HOMELESS COLOR PER FEDERAL
GUIDELINES. AND THEIR PUSH TO
ARE COORDINATED ENTRY TEAM WELL
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS
IDENTIFYING THOSE INDIVIDUAL
PUTTING HIM INTO AN H. MY A
SYSTEM WHICH IS ARE HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM.
AND THIS IS A SHARED PLATFORM
AMONG ALL HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDER SO THAT WAY WE HAVE A
SINGLE POINT OF ENTRY. FOR
EVERYONE THAT WERE SERVING IN
THE COUNTY WERE ABLE TO SEARCH
I'M WERE ABLE TO SAY. YOU KNOW
PATIENT RARE CLIENT A RATHER
CAME IN AND WENT TO ONE SERVICE
PROVIDER AND- SOMEONE LOOKING
FOR THEM FOR PAPERWORK. INSTEAD
OF GIVING THEM THE RUN AROUND
WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THEM IN
THE SYSTEM WHEN WAS THE LAST
TIME THEY WERE SEEN WHAT'S A
GAP. HOW DO WE ADDRESS IT. AND
SO THAT'S IS NOT CORNET ENTRY
PROGRAM THAT IS OPERATE UNDER
TWO ONE ONE UMBRELLA AS BEEN
WORKING REALLY WELL FOR US. TO
DATE WE'VE HANDLED ABOUT
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED CALLS IN THE
USERS HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. I'M
AND THEN CONDUCTED ABOUT
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED Q. OR TEASE
WHICH ARE QUICK REFERRAL TOOLS.
IT'S JUST DIDN'T REALLY QUICK
SNAPSHOT ASSESSMENT TO IDENTIFY
WHO THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE AND
THEN WE DO A STEP FURTHER INTO
THE V. ICE THE DOUBTS THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY FOR SINGLES AND
FAMILIES TO IDENTIFY WHERE
THEY'RE AT AND FROM SEVERITY OF
HOMELESS. ARE USE SOUT
COUCHSURFING WHICH IS NOT
CONSIDERED HOMELESS AT THIS
POINT DID YOU SLEEP IN A PARK
LAST NIGHT OKAY WELL THAT
SEVERITY LEVEL IS A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER. AND SO IT'S AWESOME
BECAUSE WERE ABLE TO PARTNER
WITH ALL OF OUR ON. HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE COUNTY
BUT ON ONLY THAT WERE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE SITTING COUNTY IN
THIS EFFORT SO IT'S NOT ONLY
ONE OR. TWO AGENCIES WORKING ON
IT IT REALLY IS A COUNTY UP FOR.
I'M SO THAT'S KIND OF A NEAT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SUPPORTED
THREE CS BG. WHAT I CAN'T
PICKED UP. FROM OTHER FOLKS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT KIND
OF NEAT INITIATIVES THAT
THEY'RE WORKING ON A WERE YOU
THE PANEL WOULD LIKE TO SEE. ON
HOUSING IS SOMETHING THAT IS
UNDER UMBRELLA THAT WERE
RESEARCHING SEE HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT EXISTING SERVICE
PROVIDERS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T WANT TO JUST. COME IN AN
OVERLAPPING DUPLICATE SERVICES
WE WANT TO SEE WHERE WE FIT IN.
ON AND THEN THE OTHER PIECE IS
GETTING A LITTLE BIT MORE
EXTENDED IN THE HOMELESS OR YOU
KNOW BY POTENTIALLY BECOMING A
DRUG SERVICE PROVIDER. WITH
THAT MEANS FOR US RIGHT NOW IS
JUST RESEARCHING OPTIONS OF
LOOKING AT LOW VERY HOUSING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS. WHAT CAN'T
ACCOUNT AGENCY DO ON TO HELP
OUR COMMUNITY. A MODEL THAT
WE'D LIKE TO LOOK AT IS CAPS
LOS TO LOSE BUT STEINBERG'S
OFFICE THEY HAVE FORTY PRADA
WHICH IS A BEAUTIFUL SIGHT. AND
IT REALLY MEET THE NEEDSOF THE
COMMUNITY AND I THINK THAT
SOMETHING OUR AGENCY COULD
POTENTIALLY DO. AND IT'S WITH
C. IS FISH G. FUNDS THEY WERE
ABLE TO. KIND OF HELP US
RESEARCH IF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT TO DO AND
POTENTIALLY YOU SEE IS THE G.
TO HELP SUPPORT THAT EFFORT.
YOU KNOW BLOCKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT WAS. THANK YOU
FOR INFORMING US ABOUT THE FORT
WORTH FIGURAL TOO LEAN VERY
INFORMATIONAL A LOT OF GREAT
THINGS GOING ON THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE WORKING ON. AT THIS
MOMENT I'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN
IT UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS WILL START WITH THEIR
CULTURE COURSE. THEY'VE ALL
DESERTED US WERE TAKING CARE OF
BUSINESS HERE. I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW YOU'VE
HEARD WHAT SOME OF THE OTHERS
ARE DOING WITH THEIR OWN
PROGRAMS AND SO MY QUESTION IS
DO YOU SPEAK REGULARLY TO ONE
ANOTHER TO FIND BEST PRACTICES
MAYBE WITH SOMEBODY ELSE IS
DOING SEE IF THAT CAN BE
DUPLICATED IN YOUR PARTICULAR
PROGRAM. SURE YEAH. JOHN I GREW
WE LEVERAGE OUR OUR MICROPHONES.
IT'S OKAY OUR OUR OUR EFFORTS
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT
METHODS OF COORDINATION
COMMUNICATION FOR INSTANCE YOU
KNOW PAT AND I SERVE ON STATE
TO MAKE CESSATION. BOARD
TOGETHER AND I'M ALWAYS
STEALING IDEAS FROM. SO YOU. I
WILL TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE A
SENIOR ADVOCACY WEEK IN THE
DISTRICT WHERE WE TAKE ONE WE
CAN WE VISIT SENIOR CENTERS
SENIOR HOUSING AND WE SCHEDULE
THESE MY FIRST YEAR IS FOURTEEN
SECOND YEAR TWENTY ONE THIS
YEAR WE HAVE THIRTY AND THIS
YEAR WE'RE GOING TO PARTNER
WITH PATRICIA AND THE
ORGANIZATION THEY'RE GOING TO
GO WITH US TO PROVIDE THE
HEALTHY FOODS FOR SENIORS AND
HYGIENE HYGIENIC PRODUCTS. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
NEVER HAVE THOUGHT OF BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THROUGH ONCE I
SAW WHAT WE WERE DOING SINCE
THE PARTNERSHIP AND I THINK
THAT CLEARLY THIS IS SOMETHING
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO WE
WERE ELECTED TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY AND ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TO PARTNER WITH ANY
ORGANIZATION. WE'RE GOING TO DO
IT. TO PROVIDE MORE SERVICE TO
THE COMMUNITY SO THAT WAS ONE
OF THE PROGRAMS I ABSOLUTELY I
AM SO GRATEFUL THAT YOU ALL ARE
GOING TO PARTNER WITH US THANK
YOU. JUST ONE MORE EXAMPLE
WOULD BE THE SYSTEM WITHIN
HOURS I REACHED OUT TO CAPS THE
NOMA WHO HAD ENDURED THE CHOIR
THE PRIOR YEAR AND WAS ABLE TO.
BECAUSE I KNEW THAT THAT. IN
SOME WAYS AND WE CAN HAVE THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO US TO
HELP PROVIDE. SOME MEASURE OF
COMFORT AND IN AN EFFECTIVE
ASSISTANCE BUT THERE ARE TO BE
THOSE FOLKS WHO ONLY WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THE END OF THE DAY
WHAT DID YOU DO WITH THE MONEY.
AND SO WE WERE FORTUNATE TO BE
ABLE TO REACH OUT TO CAPS IN
NORMAL WHO HAD OF THEIR THEIR
MODELS OF DOCUMENTATION
AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TO US. WITHIN JUST TWEAKED A
BIT SO THAT WE COULD THEN
INSURE THAT WE WERE JUST
REACHING OUT. AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE HELPS OUR FOLKS WHO
WERE. DESPERATE. THE SEMINARY
SAID. SPAHN BACK ALSO TO OTHER.
PLATFORMS WERE ABLE TO SHARE
INFORMATION AND BEST PRACTICES
OUR STATE AGENCY COMMITTEE
SOURCES BARTON VELLUM IT.
CONDUCTS MEETINGS WITH ALL
EXACT DIRECT THE COMMUNITY
ACTION AGENCIES ON A REGULAR
BASIS. AND ALSO STATE
ASSOCIATION. OF THEIR MEMBER
ORGANIZATION THAT ALLOWS LOCKED
ME ACTION AGENCIES TO. CALL
THEM FOR RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION AND THEN THE
NATIONAL CONFERENCE THAT WAS
ALLUDED TO. IT'S GOING TO BE
GOING ON THERE. AT THE END OF
THIS WEEK IS ALSO ANOTHER
PLATFORM. RECAP AGENCIES TO
ATTEND IN HERE WITH OTHER
CONNECTION ACER. ALL IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. WONDERFUL LIKED
I'M I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT. I'M
VERY GLAD TO HEAR THAT. THEY'RE
THERE SOME OF YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE CENSUS COMPLETE COUNT
TWENTY TWENTY SOME OF THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING DIRECTLY. IS ARE
ALL OF YOU DOING SOMETHING WITH
THE WITH THE CENSUS. YEAH YEAH
YEAH. COUNTY WERE PERFECT FOR
ME. THE ACCOUNT COMMITTEE AND
WHERE I'M HEADING THE
COMMUNICATIONS DEPARTMENT AT
THAT IT'S AFTER ON AND WERE
USING TWO ONE ONE TO KIND OF
LEVERAGE SOME OF THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS AND IF FOLKS
CALLING FOR ABLE TO SHARE
INFORMATION I WAS INTERESTED IN
THAT AS WELL WE HAVE A TWO ONE
ONE FOR ARE HOMELESS AND SO THE
CALL COMES DIRECTLY TO YOU
RIGHT SO DO WE OPERATE THE TWO
ONE PROGRAM INDIVIDUALS CAN
CALL INTO TWO ONE ONE. THEY GO
THROUGH I IRON OUR STAFF
MEMBERS AND THEY'RE CALLING IN
FOR HOMELESS SERVICE IN OUR
INFORMATION. REFERRAL
SPECIALIST SORRY HI SO MANY
ACRONYMS. AND SO THEN THEIR
PUSH TO OUR COORDINATED ENTRY
TEAM AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
EITHER TO ABLE TO THEN DO A-
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY GET INTO
THE SYSTEM. WONDER IS THAT
SIMILAR FOR THE REST OF YOU TWO
ONE ONE TWO ONE ONE COME TO
DIRECTLY TO YOU OKAY MEDINA
COUNTY IT IS THE INLAND EMPIRE
UNITED WASTED OVERSEAS
SUPPORTING ACTRESS SYSTEM MEAN
FOR US IS UNITED WAY AS WELL IN
OUR LOCAL AREA WONDERFUL. A
FREE SO YOU USE MISTER OXIDE IT
WAS. ONE STOP OPERATOR WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN. IT WELL THAT'S
KIND OF THE VISION OF A ONE
STOP SHOP FOR ITS LOCAL
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD HAS
BEEN DRIVING THEM MESSAGE WE'VE
BEEN DOING FOR YEARS. SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN A REYES
SERVICES FOR SOMEBODY TO GET
SOMETHING AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
WHOLE PHILOSOPHY OF US IT WE
HAVE A REYES SERVICES OR WITH
HER PARTNERS THAT WE CAN
DELIVER IT WHO CAN MAKE A GO TO
IF THEY NEED SOMETHING SOME
OUT. SO THERE'S WHAT HAPPENED
WHAT COUPLE SOMETHING RATHER
THAN NOTHING SO THAT'S THE
PHILOSOPHY THAT WE'VE HAD FOR A
LONG TIME FOR MY PERSONAL
FARMWORKERS AND DON'T GET ME
WRONG THEY GO TO THE ONE OUR
OUR POPULATION THEY THEY HAVE
MULTIPLE BARRIERS BET THAT
THEY'RE A GREAT WORKING
COMMUNITY. THEY MAY GO FOR THE
TRADITIONAL WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT ACT PROGRAMS MAY
THEY MAY HAVE A LANGUAGE OR
OTHER THINGS AS BARRIERS AND
THAT RATE FOR A FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT SO THEY ARE OFTEN
DIRECTED BACK TO ASK FOR A WE
WORK WITH THE MOST CHALLENGING
AND POPULATION WERE GLAD TO DO
THAT JUST FOR THEM TO GIVE THEM
THE HELP UP MESSI ESPECIALLY
BRINGS THAT PART OF IT. IN
LOCAL ME ACTUAL PROGRAMS AND
LOCAL CAPS TO THE SAME THING WE
HAVE A DIFFERENT KIND OF
PHILOSOPHY IN AN INTERVIEW
ENERGY TO PLAY I HAVEN'T TAKEN
EXCEPTION I GET DISCOURAGED
NUMBER. ONE STOP SYSTEM
SOMETIMES PEOPLE GET LOST. BE
ENERGETIC AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT. NO ON THIS PROPERTY
SYSTEM. SO THAT'S OUR OUR
PHILOSOPHY OUR THOUGHTS THANK
YOU I KNOW MR KERRY WHEN YOU
TALKED ABOUT YOUR WORK WITH THE
CENSUS IT'S CLEAR THAT YOU YOU
THEM TO BECOME THE MAIN
ORGANIZATION TO COUNT OUR
NATIVE AMERICANS AMERICAN.
THERE'S A WIDE NATIVE COMPLETE
CAP COMMITTEE AND ALL OF OUR
SEIZE BG NETWORK THE ENTIRE
NETWORK IS PART OF THAT
STATEWIDE SYSTEM HAS BEEN
FUNDED AND WE HAD TO TWO
MEETINGS ALREADY AND WE ARE
THERE THERE WAS A- A VERY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON INDIAN
COUNTRY AS AS ON A LOT OF NON
INDIAN PROGRAMS FROM THE LAST
CENSUS LICENSES DID NOT DO AN
ACCURATE AND COMPLETE COUNT OF
LOW INCOME PEOPLE IT DIDN'T
COLLECT THE DATA IN A WAY THAT
COULD BE USED TO ACCURATELY
PORTRAY. THE NUMBERS NECESSARY
FOR THE A PORTION OF MONEY AT
THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVELS
AND PROGRAMS BEEN SUFFERING.
SINCE THAT TIME AND WE'RE STILL
USING NINETEEN YEAR OLD. FOLKS
WALKING DOWN THE RESERVATION
DIRT ROAD TO THEIR HOUSE ON THE
TOP OF THE HILL TO ASK THEM TO
FILL OUT A FORM. TO DO THAT AND
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF REALLY
UNIQUE CHALLENGES THIS YEAR
IT'S GOIN TO BE ONLINE. HAVE
INDIAN COUNTRY DOESN'T HAVE AN
INTERNET OR COMPUTER. MOST OF
INDIAN COUNTRY IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES HAS PO BOXES THE
BOXES CAN'T DO THE ONLINE
THEY'RE GONNA GET SOMEBODY IS
GOING TO WALK UP TO THEIR DOOR
OLD SCHOOL AND GIVEN A PAPER
FORM. THEY WILL PUT IT IN THE
MAIL AND I WALK UP AND GIVE IT
TO THEM A HUGE AMOUNT OF
DISTRUST. WE'RE ESTABLISHING
QUESTION ASSISTANCE CENTERS IN
QUESTION ASSISTANCE KIOSK SO WE
CAN GO OUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND
GIVE THEM A SAFE PLACE TO COME
TO WILL HELP THEM GET THE
NUMBER THAT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT ONLINE BECAUSE
THERE IS A PROCESS TO DO THAT
IF YOU JUMP THROUGH IN A
FLAMING HOOPS. AND TRY AND GET
THEM TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A SAFE
AND COMFORTABLE PLACE THAT THEY
CAN DO THE CENSUS AND COMPLETE
THE CENSUS. AND REALLY ENGAGING
THE USE ONE OF THE WAYS WE'RE
REALIZING I CAN SIT HERE AND
TALK ABOUT THIS TERM HAS COME
HOME AND ALWAYS LISTEN TO ME.
BUT WHEN IS YOUR TEENAGE ME
SQUARE SON OR GRANDSON OR
GRANDDAUGHTER OR SOMEBODY
THAT'S TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
WHAT IS IMPORTANT THEY SEEM TO
HAVE A VOICE MORE. LISTEN TO.
REALLY I DO AND HOW ARE YOU THE
MASTER'S INDIAN. KNOW THAT IN
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. OF
CENSUS COUNT IS GOING TO BE. IT
ALWAYS IS A PROBLEM THE-
CHILDREN ARE COUNTED. OR
THERE'S ALWAYS AN UNDERCOUNT OF
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WORK REALLY
HARD IN THE NOW WITH THE- THE
RHETORIC FROM THE- AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. ABOUT
CITIZENSHIP BE ALTHOUGH IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE A QUESTION.
ENOUGH DOUBT WAS PUT INTO THE
MINDS OF PEOPLE AND- THESE ICE
RAIDS. SO WHEN. THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY WHEN. SOMEBODY COMES
KNOCKING ON THE DOOR. THEY
ALREADY THINK OF EVERYTHING
THEY'VE BEEN READ. THEY'VE BEEN
HEARING AND READING. ABOUT AND
SO THAT'S GOING TO BE A GREAT
CHALLENGE. A WORD MISTER DECIDE
THAT YOU USED. WAS TRUSTED. ON
WEEKEND. I AM SO GRATEFUL FOR
ALL OF. THE ORGANIZATIONS.
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN THERE FOR
SO MANY YEARS. THE COMMUNITY
KNOWS YOU. THE COMMITTEE HAS
RELIED ON YOU. AND THE
COMMUNITY TRUSTS YOU. SO THE
MESSAGE THE NEEDS TO GO FROM.
SACRAMENTO TO THE COMMUNITY.
SHOULD GO THROUGH YOU. BECAUSE
THE COMMUNITY DOES TRUST YOU. I
WANT TO. THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR
ALL OF THE INFORMATION YOU
PROVIDED. PLEASE. KNOW THAT I
MEET AT MY PARTNERSHIP IS RIGHT
HERE. I AM A LEGISLATIVE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
WANT TO PARTNER IN ANY WAY THAT
WE CAN WE HAVE. I CAN I CAN I
THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR ALL OF
OUR COLLEAGUES WHICH IS THE
SENATOR WHEN I SAY THAT. WE ARE
HERE TO SERVE. I GUESS THEY
DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE MY
SENTENCE. WE ARE HERE TO SERVE.
YOUR ABSOLUTELY HERE TO SERVE
AND ANYWAY THAT WE CAN SERVE
THE WE CAN PARTNER WE WILL BE
THERE. ANDY PLEASE COUNT ON US
THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS THAT
WE WANT FOR OUR COMMUNITY. AND
WE DO LOOK FOR THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT HAVE BEEN
IN OUR COMMUNITY SERVING THE
COMMUNITY AND OUR TRUSTED BY
THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU ALL SO
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SO I HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. I WANTED
TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE OF AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OF THE
JOBS TRAINING PROGRAM THAT YOU
HAVE AT AT PROTEUS IS IT IS
THERE A SPECIFIC REASON WHY YOU
KNOW YOU DO ART YOUR TRACKING
OR WE HAVE A LOCATION FOR A
SCHOOL THAT WE FOR. IF WE FORM
SOME YEARS BACK AND PART OF OUR
MISSION IS TO PROVIDE JOB
TRAINING SO WE HAVE A SKILL
CENTER AND WHICH WOULD PROVIDE.
AN RSS SERVICE CENTER. OFFICE
AUTOMATION IS BASIC OFFICE
SKILLS TRAINING. IT UNTIL
POINTS IN GETTING A JOB
HOPEFULLY AN OFFICE IN GOING TO
MAYBE SOME MEDICAL ASSISTANT OR
SOME RIDING DIFFERENT THINGS.
OR JUST JUST BASIC COMPUTER
SKILLS I THINK YOU GO WITH THIS
ONE OFFICE SETTING WE HAVE
TRUCK DRIVER TRAINEES BAND. A
PARTY A MODEL THAT HERE'S A LOT
OF JOBS IN TRACKING THE
TRUCKING INDSTRY HAS BEEN MOST
SUCCESSFUL IN FOR FARMWORKERS
FOR OUR POPULATION. EVEN THOUGH
THEY MIGHT HAVE SOME ACADEMIC
CHALLENGES AS SOMETHING AS A
QUICK JOB THEY CAN GET THE
TRAIN PASSED THE TEST AND THEN.
WE HAVE SOME OF OUR PURCHASES
THAT AREN'T THAT FORM THEIR OWN
BUSINESS ALREADY THE ONLY ONLY
TRUCKS. AND THEY COME BACK IN
AND WE COULD TRY THIS SUMMER. A
BUSINESS AND THEN WE HAVE
SOARED TRAINING WE'VE BEEN IN
THAT ARENA FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS. JUST BASIC FOR
INSULATION AND FOR. SAY A
INITIALLY WAS THE SCORE FARMS.
AND EVERYTHING ELSE AND NOW
IT'S ABOUT FOUR HOMES. BED DOWN
WITH THE PROVIDING OF TRAINING
FOR QUITE AWHILE QUITE A BIT OF
TIME ALREADY. AND WE ALSO OFFER
TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC. I
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD
STANDS PURCHASED A MR LASSEN
BECAUSE RIGHT TRAINING. AND
IT'S NOT AN INVESTMENT FOR
THEM. THE CHARGE BAY. IT'S ALSO
FOR A- FOR SOME DAY I DON'T
HAVE A CAPACITY OF SCHOLARSHIPS
TRY TO GET HIM THROUGH. OUR
MISSION FOR THE MOST PART HAS
ALWAYS BEEN AND. I WOULD SAY
ENGLISH. AND JOB PLACEMENT AND
TRAINING THAT'S WHAT WOULD
DRIVEN IS THAT'S WHAT. DRIVES
PEOPLE TO GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT IN THE
LONG RUN. AND SO ANOTHER
QUESTION I KNOW THAT BECAUSE
HAVE VERY RESPECTED
ORGANIZATION AND YOU'VE BEEN
HERE SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN
IN THE VALLEY. THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK YOU KNOW ALL
THESE YEARS. AT WHAT WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY THAT. YOU KNOW HOW
PROTEUS HAS GROWN VAULT OVER
OVER THAT TIME. WE HAVE ONE
FROM THE VERY BASICS WHILE
FORTUNATE STATION AT THE WARM
PARTLY FREQUENCY IS THE ONE
THAT THE BIRTH CAME ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY AGENCIES.
THE SAME WAY. Y. PRODUCE THE
NAME PRO IS A UNIQUE. NAME AND
I SHARED WITH THEM ARE CALLED
MCCAULEY. OUR FOUNDERS GOT
TOGETHER IN THE PHONE THAT NAME
AND IF IT MEANS FIRST OR- IT
ALSO MEANS CHANGE. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE FOUNDER STOP
APPROACH TO CHANGE
CONCENTRATION IS TRUE. MY
CAREER AND THE PRICE IS ALWAYS
ABOUT CHANGE EVEN NOW. OUR
STATE WE AS BABY BOOMERS KIND
OF SAUDI SO YOUNG. WHEN OUR
CHANGING BECAUSE THE YOUNGER
GENERATION COMING UP AND IT IS
CHANGE ORGANIZATION IS HE EVER
EVOLVING CHANGING. FROM A SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY WE'RE ALL OVER
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
STRONG NOW. AND THAT'S A LOT OF
IS BECAUSE OF THE DIVERSITY WE
BRING TO THE TABLE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. AND I CAN BEING
INVOLVED IN A LONG TIME PARTNER
BRINGS THAT TRUST FACTOR WITH A
FUNDING SOURCES. YEAH WE HOLLOW
EASE MAKE OUR PRODUCTION BUT WE
NEED TO HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- ARE STRONG AND ANYTHING
THAT WOULD TOUCH AND DEAL WITH.
AND OUR PHILOSOPHY LEAST FROM
MY LEADERSHIP ON THAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN LOW ABOUT
PARTNERSHIP. AND I REALLY
BELIEVE STRONGLY BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T DO IT ALL. PART OF THE
CHANGE. THANK YOU AND YOU KNOW
I ALSO WANTED TO ASK MR HERE.
YOU KNOW IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME AND
LEVERAGING OF. OF A FEDERAL CS
BG DOLLARS TO BRING FOOD TO THE
ELDER SHINES IN THE LAKE I
RANCHERIA CAN YOU. CAN YOU A
TELLS A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY VERY SMALL
PROGRAM BUT WHEN THIS NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART AND I THINK IT
REALLY DOES HELP ILLUSTRATE HOW
A LITTLE BIT TO SEE SB JEEP AND
GO A LONG WAY. THE BLUE LAKE
RANCHERIA HAS A ELDERS
NUTRITION PROGRAM WHERE THEY
MAKE MEALS PACKAGE UP SEVERAL
MEALS AND WOOD FROM THE ELDERS
HOME AND THEY THEY DON'T YOU
IDEAL HAVING SAILED OR NOT
SENIOR THAT'S IN IN INDIAN
COUNTRY ITSELF. BUT THEY'LL
DELIVER THE HOME SO FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE ARE ARE TRYING TO
MAINTAIN AN INDEPENDENT LIVING
STYLE AS AN ELDER THEY CAN HAVE
PRE COOKED MEALS AVAILABLE TO
THEM PULLED OUT OF THE FREEZER
BE ABLE TO MAKE THEM UP AND
IT'S A REAL VALUABLE SERVICE TO
MAINTAIN INDEPENDENCE FOR OUR
ELDER COMMUNITY. THE ADJACENT
COUNTY OF TRINITY COUNTY BLUE
LAKE RANCHERIA IS IN HUMBLE
COUNTY AND THEY HAVE A PROGRAM
IN THEIR SERVING PEOPLE ON THE
RANCHERIA AND IN IN A LARGER
AREA OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY. THERE
TRINITY COUNTY WHICH IS AN
EXTREMELY RURAL AN EXTREMELY
IMPOVERISHED ON COUNTY THIS
DIRECTLY ADJACENT A HUMBLE
DIRECTLY EAST OF IT DOES NOT
HAVE A PROGRAM. AND WE HAD
IDENTIFIED ALMOST FORTY INDIAN
ELDERS WHO WERE AT RISK OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN THEIR
INDEPENDENCE BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO PROGRAM TO SERVE THEM. AND
SO IN CA DC FOUND A VOLUNTEER
FROM THE AROUND MARK NATION AN
ELDER HIMSELF WHO SAID FOR GAS
REIMBURSEMENTS I WILL BE A
VOLUNTEER AND I WILL GO TO BLUE
LINK I WILL PICK THEM UP AND I
WILL DRIVE THEM TO ALL OF MY
FRIENDS ALL OF THESE ELDERS AND
MAKE SURE THEY EACH ONE GETS A
MEAL AND PUT HIM IN THEIR
FREEZERS AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE
OKAY AND I'LL BE SOMEBODY YOU
CAN CHECK UP ON HIM BECAUSE I
KNOW SOMETIMES. SEE SOMEBODY
FOR A FEW DAYS AND SO AND WE'VE
BEEN RUNNING THAT EVER SINCE
YOU'RE ALMOST AS INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH ONE THE NON. NOT YET
FEDERALLY ACKNOWLEDGED TRIBES.
NONPROFIT FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
THAT THEY- DO THEIR TRIBAL
THINGS THROUGH WHEN THEY'RE
DOING THE FEDERALLY KNOWLEDGE
MY PETITION. AND HAVE BEEN FOR
THIRTY YEARS. BUT AND THEN IN
THE MEANTIME THEY HELP SERVE
THE NEEDS OF INDIAN PEOPLE IN
THAT COUNTY AND THEY RECRUITED
TO VOLUNTEER AND THEY HELP
COORDINATE THE DELIVERYOF
THOSE MEALS AND- THOSE ELDERS
IN TRINITY COUNTY CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN AN INDEPENDENT LIVING.
STYLE BECAUSE OF A FEW HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR GAS TO GET THOSE
MAILED OUT TO. THANK YOU SIR.
MR TOMORROW I KNOW YOU TOUCHED
ON THIS ON THE WORK THAT YOU
THAT YOU YOU KNOW WHAT COUNTRY
THE FIRES AND- I WANTED TO KNOW.
HOW DO YOU KNOW HOW IS THE
COMMUNITY DOING HOW. CURRENTLY
AND- MR MIA. YOU KNOW THE SHORT
ANSWER IS THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE DOING I BELIEVE THE
LAST COUNT THERE WAS A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PERMITS PULLED UP ON
THE RIGID SHAFT TO FOR
REBUILDING PURPOSES BUT FORTY
THOUSAND HOMES WERE DESTROYED
THE WATER SYSTEMS TESTING IS
BEHIND SCHEDULE BECAUSE THEY
THEY CAN'T. TEST A LOT OF THE
INDIVIDUAL LOTS THEY JUST CAME
OUT OF THE STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
DO IT. AND THE ONES WHO ARE
BUILDING OR OTHERWISE HAVE WELL.
SO WITH THE FORTUNATELY THE
DEBRIS REMOVAL IS AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE ACCORDING TO FEMA THE
TO THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE COMING INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO HELP WITH SOME OF
THE RECOVERY EFFORTS IS. ON ITS
WAY ARE WE WE'RE PART OF THE
INTERNAL PART OF THE CONTINUING
CARE I HEAR IT IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND SO WE'RE
POSITIONING OUR CONTINUE CARE
TO BE A PART OF THE RECIPIENT
OF SOME OF THESE DOLLARS THAT
ARE. SUPPOSED TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA ON THE CALIFORNIA.
BUT THERE'S STILL A LOT THERE'S
A LITTLE MORE. WOULD YOU MIND
TAKING A LITTLE BIT ON LIKE THE
TYPES OF SERVICES THAT. YOU
KNOW THE SURVIVORS ARE ARE YOU
KNOW. I AM. USING NOW OR RIGHT
AROUND NOON IT'S EITHER IF WE
CAN MOVE THEM OUT OF THE HOTELS
AND MOTELS BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME STILL LIVING IN HOTELS AND
MOTELS IN THE REGION IF A
BECAUSE WE HAVE CASE MANAGERS
WHO ARE PAID OUT OF SOME OF THE
C. S. P. YOU DOLLARS THAT WE
RECEIVED. TO IDENTIFY WITH
THEIR SUPPORT STRUCTURES ARE
ELSEWHERE IF THAT'S GOING TO
REALLY BE A PART OF THEIR
FUTURE SUCCESS STORY THEN WE'RE
YOU WERE MAKING THAT AVAILABLE
TO THEM YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
NOT COURSE FORCING THEM ANYBODY
TO RELOCATE BUT- IN WHEN YOU
START COMING TO THE END OF YOUR
WHAT IS. YOUR NINTH MONTH IN A
HOTEL ROOM YOU'RE STARTING TO
LOOK AT WHAT ARE YOUR FUTURE
OPTIONS. WHETHER RICH REALLY
REALISTIC TO STAY THERE SO. IF
NOT RAPIDLY HOUSING AND
RELOCATION AND THEN CONTINUALLY
THROUGH THAT WHOLE PERIOD WE
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FOOD.
NO THEY THEY THEY CAN KIND OF
YOU I RUN THEIR CLOCKS BY OUR
OR DISTRIBUTION CENTERS HERE IS
AN HOUR STARTING TO REACH OUT
TO THE- THE FEMA COMMUNITIES
ARE POPPING UP. IN RIDLEY OR
AVAIL AND NOT YET IN CHICO.
LISTEN THOSE COMMUNITIES JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND THOSE FAMILIES
ARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR.
TRANSMISSIONS ON. I ROUTE I
WANTED TO TAKE JUST A KIND OF A
QUICK MOMENT TO ALSO TOUCH ON
NINE THE TWO ONE ONE PROGRAM IN
KERN COUNTY. JUST. A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND CALLS
RIGHT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN HE
SAID YEAH. WELL UP. SO I. I
WANTED TO GET MORE OF AN
UNDERSTANDING AND I HAVE A
CONVERSATION IS THERE FOR A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS UNDER
CONSIDERATION AND LEGISLATURE
THAT. THE SUPPORT AT THE
ENHANCEMENT OF EIGHT NO WRONG
DOOR SYSTEM FOR OLDER ADULTS
SEEKING SERVICES. AND SO ON HOW
HOW COULD CURRENT COUNTIES TO
ONE ONE PROGRAM I FIT INTO A NO
WRONG DOOR SYSTEM OR YOU KNOW
DOES IT ALREADY. SO NO WE
CURRENTLY DO NOT FOR THE
ELDERLY POPULATION AND THE
ELDERLY POPULATION WITH
DISABILITY SPECIFICALLY BUT
MORE RECENTLY THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL ON INDEPENDENT LIVING
THANK YOU OF AGING AND
DISABILITY PUBLISHED EIGHTY. A
SURVEY THAT GAVE GREAT
STRATEGIES ON WHAT OTHER FOLKS
ARE USING A DIFFERENCE STATES
AND HOW TO INCORPORATE BETTER
SERVICES THAT ARE ON PATIENT
CENTERED AND IT KIND OF LOOKED
AT THAT WHOLE PERSON CARE
MODELS SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT
POPULATION. AND I THINK OUR AYE
IN OUR STAFF FOR INFORMATION
REFERRAL STAFF COULD REALLY
FOLLOW THAT MODEL. AND AGAIN IT
LOOKS SIMILAR TO THE
COORDINATED ENTRY MODEL I KNOW
I SAID COORDINATED ENTRY FOR
HOMELESS BUT NOT MODEL CAN
APPLY TO ANY SUBPOPULATION IT'S
A MATTER OF JUST BRINGING IN. A
SUBGROUP OF INDIVIDUAL
IDENTIFYING WHO THEY ARE WHAT
SERVICES THEY'RE ACCESSING
WHERE IS THE GAPS IN SERVICES
AND HOW WE AS A CAP AGENCY AND
OR PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY
CAN ADDRESS THOSE. ON BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO MULTIPLE
PLACES RIGHT SO YOU DON'T WANT
TO DUPLICATE SERVICES ON THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING THAT WAS
PUBLISHED RECENTLY I THINK THAT
IS AN INTERESTING DOCUMENT THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS SUPPORTING. BUT
I REALLY LIKE THE STRATEGIES
AND THE OTHER DOCUMENT THAT I
MENTIONED I THINK I SHARE THAT
WITH ON YOUR TEAM BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
TO POP TO INCORPORATE INTO TWO
ONE ONE SO NOT ONLY WOULD BE
TWO ONE ONE JUST RECEIVING
CALLS BUT HOW CAN WE KIND OF.
MOVE THAT BOTTLE INTO A MORE
CASE MANAGEMENT. PATIENT
CENTERED FOCUS TYPE OF PROGRAM.
YES THE DEATH THANK YOU. OR IT
WOULD REALLY JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF
YOUR DAY TO COME UP HERE AND TO
PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY I FEEL
LIKE WE LEARNED A LOT AND I
JUST ALWAYS FEEL FREE TO.
COMMUNICATE WITH US AND LET US
KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON AND HOW
WE COULD. BE SUPPORTIVE HERE
AND KEEPING US INFORMED COURSES
REALLY IMPORTANT UP THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME HERE TODAY. IN HERE. SO
NOW AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND OPEN IT UP TO. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. SO IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
PROVIDE YOUR COMMENTS. AND WE
ARE ASKING THAT COMMENTS BE
KEPT TO NO MORE THAN THREE
MINUTES. DO WE HAVE IN. I THINK
WE HAVE NO COMMENT. OKAY. SO
ONCE AGAIN AND IF YOU. GO AHEAD
AND. YOU KNOW A HAVE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT THE HEAD AND
PROVIDE CLOSING STATEMENTS AT
THIS MOMENT THANK YOU. I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL ONCE
AGAIN FOR BEING HERE. THIS HAS
BEEN VERY INFORMATIVE WE HAVE
MUCH TO LEARN AND YOU'RE THE
ONES THAT ARE GOING TO TEACHERS
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN DOING IT
FOR YEARS. WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE- MAKE POLICY THAT WE
PASSED POLICY. THAT MAKES YOUR
LIFE EASIER WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE HAVE BUDGET ITEMS THAT
INCLUDE THE THINGS THAT YOU
NEED INCLUDED. AND WE DON'T PUT
SO MANY RESTRICTIONS ON IT THAT
IT THEN CAUSES YOU MORE
PROBLEMS IS NOT WORTH TAKING
THE MONEY BECAUSE WE'RE PUTTING
SO MANY RESTRICTIONS ON IT. AS
THE SENATOR HAS SAID
COMMUNICATE WITH US TELL US HOW
WE CAN BE HELPFUL WE WILL THEN
WORK WITH OUR COLLEAGUES TO
MAKE SURE WE GET IT PASSED. AND
I WANT TO THANK OF MOST
ESPECIALLY MY COUNTERPART IN
THE SENATE SENATOR WAS DAHLE
THOUGH FOR ALL OVER HARD WORK
IN PUTTING THIS HEARING
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU. AND WE
COMPLY WITH THE READ WITH THE-
REQUIREMENTS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN I'D LIKE TO THANK
OUR PANELISTS FOR TAKING TIME
OUT OF THEIR BUSY DAY. TO
EDUCATE THE COMMITTEES ON
BENEFITS OF THIS THE SBG
PROGRAMS YES BEACH IS OBVIOUSLY
AN IMPORTANT. UP PART POVERTY
FIGHTING WEAPON THAT IMPACTS
LIGHTS LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND IT'S
VERY IMPRESSIVE HOW ARE YOU
LEVERAGE THE FEDERAL DOLLARS.
TO CHANGE LIVES I THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK YOU DO TO BENEFIT SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. BUT ALSO WANTED AT
AT TAKE A MOMENT TO THINK. OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RAY IS FOR HER
TIME AND COMMITMENT TO OUR-COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
FOR HER. TIME AND COMMITMENT
HERE TODAY WE APPRECIATE IT AND
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR OUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER. CONSULTANTS
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY DO AND-
ET THERE'S NO WAY WE CAN DO YOU
KNOW DO THIS WITHOUT THEM SO
THANK YOU. I BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE MET OUR FEDERAL MANDATES
AT THIS HEARING AND- I CALL.
THIS HEARING AT THAT MEETING IS
ADJOURNED